I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, Angela. Hello, everyone. Hello, Jenna. Hello, everybody. Today we're breaking down the Sting. It is season seven, episode five, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Randall Einhorn. I'm excited for this one. I'm excited for so many reasons. I know, me too. Well, let me start with a summary. A handsome salesman from a rival paper company has been stealing
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。你好，安吉拉。大家好。你好，珍娜。大家好。今天我们要剖析的是《设局》。这是第七季第五集，由明迪·卡林编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。我对这一集很期待。我出于很多原因都很期待。我知道，我也是。好吧，让我从一个总结开始，来自竞争纸业公司的一个帅气推销员一直在偷走
Dunder Mifflin's clients. So Michael stages an elaborate sting operation to learn his secrets. Meanwhile, Andy starts a band with Daryl and Kevin after learning his less talented former classmate, Broccoli Rob, has had a taste of musical success. Calcy Yum. Broccoli Rob has a commercial called Calcy Yum. For the milk company. Yeah, which cracked me up because Phyllis was like, you know what? That's a really good reminder. I needed to drink milk. You know, I was the voice of like cheese, Wisconsin cheese for a year. What was your catchphrase? I can't remember if we had a catchphrase, but for a year I recorded commercials for Wisconsin cheese and talked about grilled cheese sandwiches. That's awesome. I wonder
邓德米夫林的客户。于是迈克尔策划了一场精心布置的卧底行动来探听他的秘密。与此同时，安迪在得知自己那个才华平平的前同学西兰花罗布尝到了音乐成功的滋味后，和达里尔以及凯文组建了一个乐队。卡尔西·亚姆。西兰花罗布有一个叫卡尔西·亚姆的广告。为牛奶公司拍的。是的，这让我大笑，因为菲利斯说，你知道吗？这真的是一个很好的提醒。我需要喝牛奶。你知道的，我曾做过大约一年某种奶酪的配音，威斯康星奶酪。你的口头禅是什么？我不记得我们有没有口头禅，但我连续一年为威斯康星奶酪录制广告，谈论烤奶酪三明治。太棒了。我想知道
if they exist anywhere. That makes me so happy. Well, listen, today, our fast facts are once again for the third week in a row, an interview. You guys, we are so excited. Guess who's here? We've been wanting this for a long time. It's Craig Robinson. Oh my gosh, we have been wanting this for a long time. He is busy, but he is here today and I am so excited. And we are going to ask him everything. Oh my God. Oh my God. Who is this? Who's on my screen right now? Hello, office ladies. Hi, Craig. What's up, Craig? How's it going? It's going good. Oh my God, it's so good to see your face. Likewise. What's up over there? What is this I'm looking at? You're looking
它们在什么地方还存在。这让我太开心了。好了，听着，今天我们的快讯连续第三周迎来了一场采访。大家伙儿，我们太激动了。猜猜谁来了？我们盼望这个很久了。是克雷格·罗宾逊。噢天哪，我们盼望这个很久了。他很忙，但他今天来了，我太激动了。我们要问他所有的事情。噢天哪。噢天哪。这是谁？现在谁在我的屏幕上？哈喽，办公室女士。嗨，克雷格。怎么了，克雷格？最近怎么样？挺好的。噢天哪，很高兴见到你的脸。彼此彼此。那边怎么了？我看到的是什么？你看到的是
at our office ladies studio here at Ear Wolf with lots of lamps because we can't see anymore. Yeah, we each get our own lamp at office ladies. Yeah. Only the best. Only the best. Very nice. Very nice. Well, Craig, we're going to jump right in. We always ask our guests how did they get their job on the office? I auditioned. It was Greg Daniels and then must have been 12 other people in the room and I read one of the confessionals. Yeah, the talking heads to camera. I read one of the talking heads. The beauty of my audition, the beauty and also terror was when I walked in at the time I had a video out with Jerry Miner. It was a song called Somebody's F M My Lady. Yes, very familiar. We know it.
我们在埃尔沃尔夫的办公室女士工作室，这里有好多盏灯，因为我们快什么都看不见了。是的，我们在办公室女士这儿每人分到一盏专属的灯。是的。只用最好的。只用最好的。非常好，非常好。好吧，克雷格，我们要直接切入正题了。我们总是问嘉宾，他们是怎么得到《办公室》里的工作的？我去试镜了。当时是格雷格·丹尼尔斯，房间里大概还有其他12个人，我读了一段独白。是的，对着镜头的“说话头”镜头。我读了一段“说话头”。我试镜的美妙之处，美妙同时也伴随着恐怖，那就是当我走进去的时候，当时我手里和杰瑞·迈纳有一段视频。那是一首歌，叫《某人的F M我的女士》。是的，非常熟悉。我们知道。
We're making rounds and stuff and this is obviously people look at your work before you come in to see what they're dealing with kind of thing. But at that time I didn't realize people were like looking at your work. I just thought you just went in. And Greg Daniels was like, I saw this song. It doesn't get any funnier than that. And so that could either you could take the two ways. Hey, you know, you're in and just go have a good time or wow, you're going to really mess this up now. Yeah, because you had peaked already. Yeah, exactly. So I was like, okay, but thankfully, you know, they laughed and came out as Darrell. Now when you got the role as Darrell, did you know that it was going to be recurring?
我们到处跑宣传什么的，这显然是人们在你来之前会看看你的作品，看你是什么样的人的那种情况。但当时我没意识到人们会去看你的作品。我以为你只要走进去就行了。格雷格·丹尼尔斯就说，我看了这首歌。没有比这更搞笑的了。所以你当时可以有两种理解。嘿，你知道的，你被录取了，放轻松去玩得开心吧，或者，哇，你现在真的要把这事搞砸了。是的，因为你已经达到了巅峰。是的，正好。所以我想，好吧，但谢天谢地，你知道，他们笑了，然后我就成了达里尔。现在，当你得到达里尔这个角色时，你知道它会是常驻角色吗？
Had they already decided that? No, I don't think all of that was out there yet. I do not know to be perfectly honest. But you know, I didn't pop up. It was only six episodes. I popped up in episode four, just to establish character and then episode five was basketball. We didn't know what the show was going to do yet, you know. Yeah, yeah, those were the early early days. Yeah, yeah. I remember the buzz on set when you did that introductory scene with Steve down in the warehouse where Michael comes up to you and he introduces you. And I just remember everybody being like, what has just happened? What did we just get? Because Darrell, the way Darrell looks at Michael, just all of that chemistry between
他们当时就已经决定了吗？不，我觉得当时还没定下来。说实话，我真的不知道。但你知道，我并不是一下子就出现的。总共才六集。我在第四集出现，只是为了建立角色，然后第五集是打篮球。当时我们还不知道这剧会发展成什么样，你知道的。对，对，那是早期中的早期。对，对。我记得你在仓库里和史蒂夫拍那场介绍戏时，迈克尔向你走过来并把你介绍给大家，当时片场引起了轰动。我只记得每个人都在说，刚才发生了什么？我们刚刚得到了什么？因为达里尔，达里尔看着迈克尔的眼神，那两个角色之间的所有化学反应，
those two characters, we hadn't had yet on the show and people flipped out. Wow, I had no idea. I was just staring, trying to do a good job. I didn't know there was buzz. There was buzz, Craig. There was tons of buzz. Well, you know, we're rewatching this show now. For the first time, we're seeing these episodes we haven't seen in a long time. And Craig, I lost my mind in episode employee transfer when Darrell is helping Michael and Holly move to Nashua. I could not stop laughing. I was laughing so hard I was crying. It hands down one of my favorite episodes. And Amy Ryan was on and she said doing those scenes with you and Steve was quote, I'm quoting Amy Ryan, one of the highlights of her time
我们在剧里之前从没见过，人们都疯狂了。哇，我完全不知道。我只是盯着看，努力做好工作。我不知道有什么轰动。有轰动，克雷格。有超多的轰动。好吧，你知道的，我们现在正在重温这部剧。我们是第一次看到这些我们好久没看过的剧集。而且克雷格，在《员工调动》那一集里，达里尔帮迈克尔和霍莉搬到纳舒厄时，我简直要疯了。我笑得停不下来。我笑得太厉害都哭了。这绝对是我最喜欢的剧集之一。艾米·瑞安上节目时说过，和你们俩——你和史蒂夫拍那些戏是——我引用艾米·瑞安的话——她在《办公室》里
on the office. I call her my suit. We were super friends. Yeah, that was that was hysterical riding down there. I don't know if you noticed my voice at that time was a little I needed surgery on my voice. I had a pilot. It was it was crazy riding with with those two. You know, anytime you guys seen with Michael, it was like, oh, here we go. So so they had the three of us riding down there. And it was just we did what was what do you say? He woke up and she was crying. He was like, did Darrell touch you? Yeah. Well, do you have a favorite episode from your time on the office? I know that's such a big question. And people ask us that and we have so many. But is there a moment
最棒的时光之一。我叫她我的西装。我们是超级朋友。是的，那次车程简直太爆笑了。我不知道你们有没有注意到，我当时的声音有点——我的声音需要做手术。我当时有个试播集。和那两个人一起坐车太疯狂了。你知道的，你们和迈克尔一起的任何戏，都像是，哦，我们要开始了。所以——所以他们安排我们三个坐在车里。这就好像是——你们怎么说的？他醒来时她在哭。他说，达里尔碰你了吗？好吧，你在《办公室》的日子里，有没有最喜欢的一集？我知道这是一个很大的问题。人们经常问我们这个，我们有太多喜欢的了。但是有没有哪个时刻
that really stands out as one of your favorites? You know, the Lady Clothes episode I thought was when he negotiation think it was caught. Uh huh. I had to talk Mike into going to ask for a raise so I can get a raise on Lady Clothes. The yeah, that was that's that's a standout for me. And also, you know, a scene stands out a lot that I really love was when the white light and said he went to the dentist. And Michael was like, uh, what's the name of the dentist? He was like, Crentist. But the way it was shot and it felt like a Western and you really felt the tension that that's going to stand out.
真正脱颖而出成为你的最爱之一？你知道，女士服装那一集，我觉得当时有段谈判，我觉得是被抓包了。嗯哼。我得说服迈克尔去要求加薪，这样我才能在女士服装上加薪。对，那是——那对我来说是一个亮点。还有，你知道，有一个场景非常突出，我也真的很喜欢，那就是当——白光说他去看牙医了。迈克尔问，呃，牙医叫什么名字？他说，克兰蒂斯。但那个镜头的拍摄方式感觉像是一部西部片，你真的能感受到那种紧张感，这会让人印象深刻。
Well, the cast used to love it when you would play music in an episode, we would all end up singing together. We know your mom was a music teacher and she plays organ and was first chair cello player. Mm hmm. Was she your first music teacher? Yes. Absolutely. My fact, you know, I like to say we learned in the womb, you know, she was always playing and singing to us. And then yeah, then she started to teach us. Um, but it was kind of funny her teaching. I don't know. So we ended up watching like several different teachers growing up, but she definitely was the first. What was the first instrument you learned? Piano. And how many instruments do you play?
好吧，以前每当你在剧中弹奏音乐时，演员们总是很喜欢，我们最后都会一起唱歌。我们知道你妈妈是一名音乐老师，她弹管风琴，而且是大提琴首席。嗯哼。她是你第一个音乐老师吗？是的。绝对是。事实上，你知道，我喜欢说是我们在子宫里就学会了，你知道的，她总是给我们弹奏和唱歌。然后，是的，接着她开始教我们。嗯，但她教琴的过程挺搞笑的。我不知道。所以我们长大后最终接触了几个不同的老师，但她绝对是第一个。你学的第一件乐器是什么？钢琴。你会玩多少种乐器？
I dabble in other instruments. I could figure out things on, you know, the bass or the drums or guitar or saxophone trumpet. I dabble, but I wouldn't dare say I play, you know, and I would insult actual players for the piano. That's that's my thing. Okay. So in this week's episode, the sting, Darrell, Andy and Kevin all joined together to play Andy's original song, please, Mr. President. And this sets off a really fun arc for you guys playing together. We did some research, Craig, and you guys play in Pam's replacement. The last day in Florida, you also play in local ad. You sing everyone's favorite people's person's paper people. And then your band, the nasty delicious with your
我在其他乐器上只是略懂皮毛。我能在，你知道的，贝斯、架子鼓、吉他、萨克斯或小号上弄出点动静。我只是略懂，但我绝不敢说我会玩，你知道的，那样会侮辱真正的乐手。至于钢琴，那是我的拿手绝活。好吧，在本周的这一集《设局》中，达里尔、安迪和凯文聚在一起演奏了安迪的原创歌曲《请，总统先生》。这为你们几个一起演奏开启了一个非常有趣的剧情线。我们做了一些研究，克雷格，你们在《潘的替代者》中演奏过。在佛罗里达的最后一天，你们也在《本地广告》里演奏过。你们唱了每个人最喜欢的“全人类的纸业人”。然后还有你的乐队，由你和你的
brother, Chris Rob played in Goodbye Toby part two. I mean, you got to do so many cool like performances within the show. Was there one of the songs you guys performed together that was your favorite or a standout memory? No, that Goodbye Toby episode was, was wonderful. First, you know, I got to put my band in there and my brother. And then, you know, we would just just to be featured up there like that. If you watch that episode, though, I'm gonna give away something probably nobody else would notice. But there's one part with my with the editing, with my guitar player is just jamming, but you don't hear any guitar jamming out. And so, and I, you know, of course, I'm a
兄弟克里斯·罗布组建的“讨厌的美味”，在《告别托比（下）》中演奏过。我的意思是，你在剧中有机会做那么多酷炫的表演！你们一起表演过的歌曲中，有没有哪一首是你的最爱，或者是让你印象深刻的记忆？不，那集《告别托比》真的很棒。首先，你知道的，我能把我的乐队和我的兄弟弄进去了。然后，你知道的，能像那样在上面露面。不过如果你看了那一集，我要剧透一个可能别人都不会注意到的细节。但其中有一个部分，在剪辑上，我的吉他手正在即兴狂飙，但你根本听不到任何吉他狂飙的声音。所以，而且我，你知道的，当然，我是一个
no stack. But that that Goodbye Toby was, was pretty special. I had to learn a song on the spot. I hadn't learned that song. And then I was like, Oh, that's right. Goodbye Toby. So luckily, I'm familiar with it. But yeah, it was that was cool. That would happen to you and Ed a lot. Yeah, talk to Ed on the podcast. And he said you guys rarely got very much time or notice. So rehearse. Yeah, it would just be Oh, you'd find out about it in a table read, or maybe maybe somebody would come to your trailer and be like, Hey, tomorrow, I'm going to need you to play this. Or maybe the moment like you're saying like for Goodbye Toby. Yeah. But the, the Dunn and Mifflin song, you know,
笨蛋。但那集《告别托比》真的很特别。我得当场学会一首歌。我之前没学过那首歌。然后我就想，哦，对了，告别托比。所以幸运的是，我很熟悉它。不过，是的，那真的很酷。你和埃德经常遇到这种情况。对，在播客上和埃德聊过，他说你们俩很少有充足的时间或通知来排练。是的，通常就是——哦，你会在围读剧本时发现，或者可能有人会来到你的房车里说，嘿，明天我需要你弹这个。或者可能就像你说的，就像《告别托比》那样。对，但是，邓德米夫林的这首歌，你知道的，
BJ's brother wrote the original, the Dunderman, the paper version. And then they gave it to me to kind of flip it, you know, for the story. And I got I think I did that like the night before. So that was cool. Had a little time for that. But yeah, sometimes it just be. That is amazing. You know, you and I were at Creed Bratton show and you started playing that on the piano and the place went berserk. I mean, the minute you sat down to the keyboard and just started, they all started singing. They knew immediately. It was so cool. I mean, Craig, I never get to be on stage in a band. And that was I had the tambourine. I think someone handed me a tambourine. That was the closest like moment to feeling like a rock
BJ的兄弟写了原版，也就是邓德曼和纸业版。然后他们把它交给我，让我为了剧情需要做个改编。我记得我大概是前一天晚上才做完的。所以那挺酷的。为此有点时间。不过，是的，有时候就是这么仓促。太惊人了。你知道的，你和我当时都在克里·布拉顿的演出现场，你开始在钢琴上弹奏那首歌，全场顿时沸腾了。我的意思是，你一坐在琴键前刚开始弹，他们就全开始合唱了。他们立刻就认出来了。太酷了。我的意思是，克雷格，我从来没有机会在乐队里登台演出。而那次——我拿了手铃。我想有人递给我一个手铃。那是最接近摇滚巨星感觉的时刻。
star. I thought it was so fun. Well, just being on the office and you got to you got to be a rock star at least two times in your life from going to Scranton. Those two times you already know they lost their mind. But yes, sometimes I'll play it at the show. My comedy shows out of paper and then like some whether it's a group or just one person knowing it is always satisfying. Because I mean, how many times you have to have watched the series to know that song and know the words, you know, specifically. Yeah. Well, we know you also have an improv background. You studied at Second City in Chicago. Is there an improvised moment that
我觉得太有趣了。好吧，只要在《办公室》里，你至少有两次在生活中当过摇滚巨星，从去斯克兰顿开始。那两次你已经知道他们有多疯狂了。不过是的，有时候我会在演出中弹奏它。我的喜剧演出是关于纸张的，然后像有些时候，不管是群体还是只有一个人听懂了，总是会让人感到满足。因为我的意思是，你得把这个系列看过多少遍才能知道那首歌并记住歌词，特别是那些词。是的。好吧，我们知道你也有即兴表演的背景。你在芝加哥的第二城喜剧团学习过。有没有哪个即兴的时刻
you can remember from the show that you particularly love? Angela always says if an improviser gets a moment into a TV show or a movie, you never forget it. You never forget it. So we're curious if you had one. Oh, I mean, I have several and a negotiation. And I was telling Mike, I was like, yeah, come on, go get the raise and make it happen, Captain. And I said that make it happen, Captain. Right. And then Steve turned around and I didn't see realize this until I watched it. He said, I will make it happen. Sergeant. And I was like, oh, wow, I don't even see that happen all set. Okay. That's awesome. Well, I have a favorite Daryl moment from this rewatch. It's season three back from vacation. That's the one where
是你从剧中能记住并且特别喜欢的？安吉拉总说，如果一个即兴演员能在电视剧或电影里保留一个即兴瞬间，你永远都不会忘记它。你永远不会忘记它。所以我们很好奇你有没有这样的时刻。哦，我的意思是，我有好几个。在《谈判》那一幕里。我当时告诉迈克尔，我说，对，来吧，去争取加薪，让它发生吧，船长。我当时说了“让它发生吧，船长”。对。然后史蒂夫转过身来——直到我回看的时候我才意识到这一点。他说，我会让它发生的，中士。然后我想，哦，哇，我在片场时甚至都没看到这一幕发生。好吧。太棒了。好吧，在这次重温中，我有一个最喜欢的达里尔时刻。那是第三季《度假归来》。就是那一集，
Michael realizes that he accidentally emailed the topless photo of Jan to everybody in the whole office. And he runs down to the warehouse because he wants you to delete it from your computer. And when he gets in there, you're sitting there, you have your feet up on the desk and you're eating a plate of food. And you say, I don't know, I'm really busy, Michael. And I went, when I saw that moment, I went and I checked the script and there is no mention that Daryl is eating a plate of food. And so I asked writer Justin Spitzer about it. And he said that that was your idea that you went over to crafty and you grabbed a plate of food before the scene started. Yeah, I want to look as not busy, but to say I was busy. So yeah.
迈克尔意识到他误把简的半裸照发给了整个办公室的每个人。他跑到仓库去，因为他想让你从电脑里删掉它。当他走进去时，你坐在那儿，把脚抬在桌上，正吃着一盘食物。你说，我不知道，我真的很忙，迈克尔。我当时想，当我看到那一幕时，我去查了剧本，上面根本没提到达里尔在吃盘子里的食物。于是我问了编剧贾斯汀·斯皮策关于这事。他说那是你的主意，你在场景开始前走到剧组的零食区拿了一盘食物。是的，我想让自己看起来不忙，但嘴上说我很忙。所以，是的。
Well, the reason I was suspicious was because I looked at the food on the plate and you recognize the food. That looks a lot like our hot snack. I mean, that looks like right after 1030. That's not still shade. That was, you know, a grab and go. Yeah, that's right. Did you oh, speaking of hot snack, do you have a favorite hot snack? I would kill the pastrami sandwich. Oh, yeah. For those who don't know, the way they fed us on that show, breakfast in the morning, three hours later, hot snack, three hours later lunch, three hours later, hot snack. And then a lot of times there was second meal. It was torturous and wonderful and wonderful. I found an email thread in my digital clutter where we were all going back and forth as a
嗯，我起因是怀疑，因为我看了盘子里的食物，你认得那食物。那看起来很像我们的热零食。我的意思是，那看起来就像十点半之后的事。那可不是什么阴影。那是，你知道的，拿了就走的零食。是的，没错。对了，说到热零食，你有什么最喜欢的吗？我简直愿意为帕过去三明治拼命。哦，是的。对于不知道的人来说，他们在那个剧组里喂我们的方式是：早上吃早餐，三小时后吃热零食，三小时后吃午餐，三小时后又吃热零食。然后很多时候还有第二餐。那真是折磨又美妙，美妙极了。我在我的数码杂物里发现了一封电子邮件串，我们当时在来回讨论...
cast about the albanda gas soup that Bartan would put out. There was a whole email thread about it because I guess one week we didn't get it and everyone was like, where's the soup? I remember the first time they put out turkey chili and then we wanted it every day. Oh, yeah. Thank you. That was John's favorite, I think, and Ed. Well, we talk a lot about behind-the-scenes moments. You know, obviously, Jen and I, we are watching this and remembering all kinds of stuff, but do you have a favorite behind-the-scenes moment where we would mess with each other or just do anything? Man, oh, my God. You know, I was thoroughly entertained coming to work every day watching, just sitting back watching y'all for the most part. Do you remember when
关于巴坦会推出的阿尔班达蔬菜汤的演员阵容。有一个专门讨论它的电子邮件串，因为我想有一周我们没喝到，每个人都在问，汤去哪儿了？我记得他们第一次推出火鸡辣椒汤时，我们就天天都想喝。哦，是的。谢谢。我想那是约翰的最爱，还有埃德。嗯，我们经常谈论幕后时刻。你知道的，显然，简和我，我们看着这些并回忆起各种各样的事情，但你有没有哪个最喜欢的幕后时刻，是我们互相恶搞或者随便做什么的？天哪，天啊。你知道的，我每天来上班都看得津津有味，看着，只是坐着看你们的大部分表演。你还记得当...
what was the one, when Rain was on the tightrope? Yes. Oh, my God. That still haunts me to this day. Him trying to balance. Yeah. And we were all just laughing, trying to hold our laugh in, but I just remember the laughter on his face. Oh, man. I have found some old videos from my, I mean, old phone. Remember the phones we had? Like the, you could kind of video off a flip phone? Yeah. And I have a real grainy video of you and Ed and Kate singing your hearts out. And Ellie, it was like in between scenes for a Halloween episode. And Craig, I mean, I texted it to you. Did you get to see it like ages ago? No, I don't remember that. What? Oh, my gosh. Oh, I'm sending it because you guys are having so much fun. Oh, no. Who did I text it to? I might not have
哪个来着，莱恩走钢丝的时候？是的。哦，天哪。那件事至今还在困扰着我。他试图保持平衡。是的。我们当时都在笑，强忍着不笑，但我只记得他脸上的笑容。哦，天哪。我从我的，我是说旧手机里找到了一些旧视频。还记得我们当年的手机吗？就像那种，你可以在翻盖手机上录像的那种？是的。我有一段非常模糊的视频，是你、埃德和凯特在声嘶力竭地唱歌。还有艾莉，那好像是在万圣节剧集的场景间隙。还有克雷格，我是说，我发短信给你了。你很久以前看到了吗？不，我不记得那个了。什么？哦，天哪。哦，我要发给你，因为你们当时玩得太开心了。哦，不。我发给谁了？我可能没有...
your correct number anymore. Oh, crap. Email me your phone number. You might be my old number. Somebody has my old number and they're, I guess, very polite telling people, hey, he doesn't, this isn't his number anymore. I should probably coordinate with them and say, hey, could you send them this way? Yeah. All right. I've got a question for you, Craig. Is there a Daryl quote that fans say to you when they see you out? Like for example, people always shout save bandit at Angela. Oh my gosh, Craig. So many people want me to save bandit. Thinkin' Flicka all day long. Thinkin' Flicka? Give it a bop, give it a zopity all day long. Yes. A storm. Well, did you keep anything from the set when we wrapped? Because we all took a
你现在的正确电话号码了。哦，糟糕。发电子邮件把你的电话号码给我。你可能用的是我的旧号码。有人拿着我的旧号码，而且我猜他们非常礼貌地告诉大家，嘿，这不是他的号码了。我可能应该和他们协调一下，说，嘿，你能把这个转发过去吗？好的。克雷格，我有个问题要问你。当粉丝们在外面见到你时，有没有哪句达里尔的台词是他们对你说的？比如，大家总是对安吉拉喊“救救班迪特”。哦天哪，克雷格。很多人都想让我救班迪特。整天想着弗利卡。想着弗利卡？按一下，整天按一下。是的。太疯狂了。嗯，杀青时你从片场拿了什么东西吗？因为我们都拿了...
little something. You know, I think I took that little monkey. You remember that? It was a little monkey over there. You know who was obsessed with that little monkey was my daughter, Isabel. She would go and find it and squeeze it. And then it would, you know, it made so much noise. How was Isabel? Oh my goodness. How old is she now? She's 14. What? Oh my gosh. It freaks people out that worked with us back then when they see her now. Jeez, yeah. No kidding. She was a little kid on set. I have to bring this up, Craig. I loved you so much as Doug Judy on Brooklyn Nine-Nine. That is such a phenomenal character. If you guys haven't watched Craig on Brooklyn Nine-Nine, you've got to go see it. I mean, I lived for him.
一点小东西。你知道，我想我拿了那个小猴子。你还记得那个吗？那边有一只小猴子。你知道谁对那只小猴子着迷吗？是我的女儿伊莎贝尔。她会去找它并捏它。然后它就会，你知道的，发出好大的声音。伊莎贝尔怎么样了？哦，天哪。她现在多大了？她14岁了。什么？哦，天哪。当现在看到她时，当年和我们一起工作的人都会大吃一惊。天哪，是啊。真的吗。她在片场时还是个小孩子呢。我得提一下这个，克雷格。我在《神烦警探》里太喜欢你演的道格·朱迪了。那真的是个非常了不起的角色。如果你们还没看过克雷格演的《神烦警探》，你们一定要去看。我的意思是，我就是为他看的。
Thank you. Thank you. That was so much fun. You know, I was doing that in the office. So, because every year they had me do an episode or whatever. But yeah, Andy Samberg, I don't know if you all know Andy, but like working with him, it was like two kids coming together. You don't see two kids just coming together. It was that for real. It has that energy, actually. It really does. I mean, I just rewatched you guys in the convertible, singing about the shoes. It's like, that is so great. I guarantee it was an improvised song. I'm putting that in our Office Ladies Instastories because it's so good. Is there anything you're working on now that we can share? Yes. Yes, I'm on a roll right now. I have a show set September 22nd,
谢谢。谢谢。那太有趣了。你知道的，我当时在《办公室》里也在做那件事。因为他们每年都让我拍一集或者别的什么。但是，是的，安迪·萨姆伯格，我不知道你们是否都知道安迪，但和他一起工作，就像两个小孩子聚在了一起。你很少见到两个小孩子就这么自然地玩到一起。那真的是那样。其实真的有那种能量。确实如此。我的意思是，我刚刚重温了你们在敞篷车里唱关于鞋子的歌。就像，那真是太棒了。我保证那是一首即兴创作的歌。我要把它发到我们的《办公室女士》Instagram快拍里，因为它太棒了。你现在有什么正在进行的工作可以和我们分享吗？有的。是的，我最近正处于上升期。我有一场演出安排在9月22日，
in Brooklyn at Brooklyn Bowl. If anybody's interested in that. And then coming up, let me see the 23rd, Governor's Long Island. And then the 25th, Toronto, JFL, just for laughs. But other than that, we're going to start shooting season two of my show on streaming service, Peacock TV. Woo! Killing it is so good. Thank you. Jen and I got to watch the pilot just the other day, and it is so funny. And I did not see that second part coming. I don't want to give anything away. There's some things coming in that's going to make your mouth drop a little bit, but they're very funny. Craig, who is the Australian actress who stars in that?
在布鲁克林的布鲁克林碗。如果有人对那个感兴趣的话。接下来，让我看看23日，长岛总督。然后是25日的的多伦多，JFL，“纯粹喜剧”喜剧节。除此之外，我们将开始拍摄我的流媒体服务Peacock TV节目的第二季。哇！太棒了。谢谢。简和我前几天刚看了试播集，真的是太搞笑了。而且我没料到会有第二部分。我不想剧透。接下来的某些内容会让你惊掉下巴，但它们非常有趣。克雷格，在里面主演的那个澳大利亚女演员是谁？
Bonnie Odorty. Oh, I love you two together. She's so good. She's brilliant. Her sense of self and sense of timing and comedy, she's so great to work with. Do you guys improv a lot on that show? We get some chances for sure to improv. And yeah, we have some fun making stuff up. You guys are an amazing duo, like your chemistry. I just want you two to be stuck in a car all the time, basically. It was actually very similar to like the Michael Scott Darrell stuck in a car energy. So good. But in the show and killing it, it's so great because you get the opportunity to be the funny man and the straight man. We saw so much of the
邦妮·奥多蒂。哦，我太喜欢你们俩在一起了。她太棒了。她才华横溢。她的自我意识、节奏感和喜剧感，和她合作太棒了。你们俩在那部剧里经常即兴表演吗？我们确实有一些即兴表演的机会。是的，我们编造东西玩得很开心。你们俩是一个了不起的二人组，就像你们的化学反应。我基本上只想让你们俩一直被困在车里。这其实非常类似于迈克尔·斯科特和达里尔被困在车里的能量。太棒了。但在《抢钱对决》中，这真的很棒，因为你有机会扮演滑稽角色和严肃角色。我们看到了很多...
straight man side of you on the office and killing it, I feel like we get the full Craig Robinson. Yeah, it's definitely opened me up a little bit to showcase some different sides. So I'm appreciative and I love the show. I love doing it. I love going to work. We were shooting New Orleans and now we're going to shoot in LA. So fun and interesting. Yeah. Well, if you need to middle-aged ladies to just, you know, do a pop in on killing it, we're available. Come on down. And also, Craig, I saw on your website, Mr. Craig Robinson.com, all of your show dates and everything up to date. So whoever's doing your website is doing a real good job. So if you guys want to catch Craig, go to his website. My God, it's so good to see you.
你在《办公室》和《抢钱对决》中严肃的一面，我觉得我们看到了完整的克雷格·罗宾逊。是的，这确实让我稍微打开了一些，展现了不同的一面。所以我很感激，我也很喜欢这部剧。我喜欢拍它。我喜欢去上班。我们以前在在新奥尔良拍戏，现在我们要去洛杉矶拍了。又好玩又有趣。是的。嗯，如果你需要两个中年女士来客串一下《抢钱对决》，我们随时待命。快来吧。另外，克雷格，我在你的网站Mr. Craig Robinson.com上看到了你所有的演出日期和所有最新信息。所以无论谁在帮你打理网站，都做得非常好。因此，如果你们想看克雷格的演出，就去他的网站吧。天哪，见到你太高兴了。
And y'all too. Thank you so much. Yeah. Craig, is there anything that we missed? Anything else you'd like to share about your time on the office or what it's meant to you? I mean, you know, it's like being on the office is like you're everybody's friend. Like everywhere I go, somebody's ready to buy you a drink or some chef's story. Some stories I give, like this is the only time my family comes together or my mother was sick and this one thing made her laugh. You know, it's all these incredible stories about people bonding with the office. And now people have seen it, you know, nine, 10, 14 times through. And it's somebody's like, it's on constant loop in my house. It's just such a blessing to be a part of that. And, you know,
你们也是。非常感谢。是的。克雷格，有什么我们漏掉的吗？关于你在《办公室》的时光或者它对你的意义，你还有什么想分享的吗？我的意思是，你知道的，在《办公室》里就像你是所有人的朋友。无论我走到哪里，总有人准备给你买杯饮料或讲个大厨的故事。我听到的一些故事就像，这是我家人唯一聚在一起的时候，或者我母亲生病了，而这唯一的一件事让她笑了。你知道的，所有这些关于人们与《办公室》产生共鸣的不可思议的故事。现在人们已经看了，你知道的，九遍、十遍、十四遍。有人觉得，这在我的家里无限循环播放。能成为其中的一部分真的是一种福气，而且，你知道的，
it's a blessing to share with you ladies. You know, we had some good times over. Yeah, we did. Well, Craig, we love you. It was so good to see you. Like, thank you so much for having me, ladies. Everybody around the world are like, do office ladies, do office ladies. I'm Brian, I'm Brian. Well, we love you. Big hugs. Big hugs, Craig. I want to see you in person soon. Yeah, just let me know. All right. All right. Yeah, we good. Thank you. We are back. It was so awesome talking to Craig. My gosh. I love them. I love them. To start this episode, Sam, Cassie, Jenna, I have a question for you. What? Yeah. Okay. Question for you. Do you want more freedom, less freedom, or to stay
能与你们几位女士分享也是一种福气。你知道的，我们度过了一些美好的时光。是的，我们确实如此。嗯，克雷格，我们爱你。见到你太棒了。非常感谢邀请我，女士们。世界各地的人都在说，出《办公室女士》吧，出《办公室女士》吧。我是布莱恩，我是布莱恩。嗯，我们爱你。大大的拥抱。大大的拥抱，克雷格。我希望很快能亲自见到你。好的，没问题。好的。好的。太好了。谢谢。我们回来了。和克雷格聊天太棒了。天哪。我爱死他们了。我爱死他们了。节目开始时，萨姆、卡茜、珍娜，我有一个问题要问你们。什么？好吧。问你们一个问题。你们想要更多的自由，更少的自由，还是保持现状？
the same? I think I always want more freedom. You are a Danny. I'm also going to go with more. You are a Danny. I'm a Danny. Danny's all around. What about you, Ange? I think I'm a Danny. Okay. Don't mess with my stuff. I want my freedom. Well, let me ask you this. Do you guys want a better life, a worse life, or do you want your life to stay the same? I'm going to say better. You're going with better? I'm going to have to get cocky. Cassie left the room. I'm going to assume she was going to go for better. Okay. I like my life. You want it to stay the same? Yeah, I'm happy in my life. But I mean, wouldn't better just be even better than the life you already like? I'm happy. I am too. I mean, listen, if my life stayed the same, I wouldn't be upset.
我想我总是想要更多的自由。你真是个丹尼。我也选更多。你是个丹尼。我是个丹尼。到处都是丹尼。你呢，安吉？我想我是个丹尼。好吧。别碰我的东西。我想要我的自由。好吧，那我问你们这个。你们想要更好的生活，更糟的生活，还是希望生活保持现状？我选更好。你选更好？我得变得自大一点了。卡茜离开房间了。我猜她会选更好。好吧。我喜欢我的生活。你希望它保持现状？是的，我对我的生活很满意。但我的意思是，难道更好不就会比你原本就喜欢的还要好吗？我很满意。我也是。我的意思是，听着，如果我的生活保持现状，我也不会沮丧。
Yeah, I don't know. That's a tricky one because it's like, I'm so thankful for what I have. I don't want to be too greedy. I'm so happy. Okay, so we'll keep the life we have, but with more freedom. Yeah, we're half Danny. We're half Danny. This episode opens with Oscar in the parking lot. He has a new bike. He's a cyclist. Who knew? Who knew? Did you catch the Pamsas? I did. It was so delicious to me. I really felt like we had to hear it. Sam, can you please play it? Love cycling. Andy, I feel like a tourist in my own city. I literally can't wait to wake up every morning. Okay. She is cute. Can't beat a horse. Okay. But then I love Dwight's line where he says it can't beat a horse. It's a bike that
是的，我不知道。这是个棘手的问题，因为我想，我很感激我所拥有的一切。我不想太贪心。我非常高兴。好吧，那我们就保持现状的生活，但拥有更多的自由。是的，我们是一半丹尼。我们是一半丹尼。本集的开头是奥斯卡在停车场。他有一辆新自行车。他是个骑行者。谁能想到呢？谁能想到呢？你注意到帕姆的台词了吗？我注意到了。我觉得它对我来说太有趣了。我真的觉得我们必须听听看。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？热爱骑行。安迪，我觉得我像个自己城市的游客。我简直迫不及待地想每天早上醒来。好吧。她好可爱。马可比不上。好吧。但后来我喜欢德怀特的台词，他说马可比不上。这是一辆...
pedals itself. I mean, it's kind of true. That okay, though, that you did to me was just you. Okay. Okay. All right, buddy. Give it a rest. Well, at 18 seconds, Kevin refers to Oscar's bike as Lance Armstrong's bike. Turns out, Phil Shea and Randy Cordray reached out to Trek bikes there in Wisconsin, and they were the product sponsors for Lance Armstrong's Tour de France victories. Wow. Yeah. They connected with Trek bikes, head of public relations, who turns out was a huge fan of the office, and they gave us two bikes, two of the Madone or Madone models. They were the exact same bike that Lance Armstrong used. Randy said that they were full carbon fiber frames with top of the line wheels, drive trains.
自己会踩的自行车。我的意思是，这倒也差不多。不过，你刚才对我说的那声“好吧”完全就是你自己的风格。好吧。好吧。好了，伙计。歇会儿吧。嗯，在18秒处，凯文把奥斯卡的自行车称为兰斯·阿姆斯特朗的自行车。原来，菲尔·谢伊和兰迪·科德雷联系了威斯康星州的崔克（Trek）自行车公司，他们是兰斯·阿姆斯特朗环法自行车赛夺冠的产品赞助商。哇。是的。他们联系了崔克自行车的公共关系负责人，原来对方是《办公室》的超级粉丝，他们送了我们两辆自行车，两辆Madone或同款车型。它们和兰斯·阿姆斯特朗使用的一模一样。兰迪说它们是全碳纤维车架，配有顶级车轮和传动系统。
At the time, these bikes retailed for around $6,000. Come on. He said a similar bike today would probably be near double that. I got my bike at Target. I don't even have a bike. So you're doing better than I am. That is a nice bicycle. Well, Michael's going to decide that he needs to ride it. Yeah, Michael really wants to ride the bicycle, puts the helmet on, he gets on. He does need Jim and Pam's help. He cannot steer it. He explains to them he used to have the little wheels in the back. We had a fan question from Lana W and Atlanta, Georgia. During the cold open, Jim and Pam are helping Michael on the bike and at 49 seconds, what is happening on Pam's face? What? Jenna, are you about to break or sneeze in this moment? Lana, I saw it.
当时这些自行车的零售价约为6000美元。拜托。他说现在一辆类似的自行车可能会翻倍。我的自行车是在塔吉特买的。我甚至没有自行车。所以你过得比我好。那真是一辆漂亮的自行车。嗯，迈克尔决定他需要骑它。是的，迈克尔真的很想骑这辆自行车，戴上头盔，他上去了。他确实需要吉姆和帕姆的帮忙。他无法控制方向。他向他们解释说他以前后面有小轮子。我们有一个来自亚特兰大佐治亚州的拉娜W的粉丝提问。在冷场开场时，吉姆和帕姆在自行车上帮迈克尔，在49秒时，帕姆的脸怎么了？什么？珍娜，你在这个时刻是要笑场还是要打喷嚏？拉娜，我看到了。
I missed it. What are you doing? I can't believe you missed it. It is the most ridiculous moment of mugging that I do on the show so far. In my opinion, that was me acting like Michael was heavy. Oh, no. That was some face acting to indicate that Michael is very heavy. I can't wait. I want to go back and see it. Either that or maybe like the pedal was actually digging into my shin and I was in pain. It looks like I'm screaming without making a noise. It's really over the top. Well, shortly after Pam has that expression on her face, Michael is going to be able to ride a little bit and then he crashes. He does. Randy told us we did two takes of this crash and we used Steve Stuntdouble Eric Solke. That is who actually crashed and then we did
我错过了。你在干什么？我真不敢相信你错过了。这是我在剧里做过的最荒谬的搞怪时刻之一。在我看来，那是我在假装迈克尔很重。哦，不。那是一些面部演技，用来暗示迈克尔非常重。我等不及了。我想回去看看。要么就是那个脚踏板真的扎进我的小腿里了，我在痛苦中。那看起来就像我在无声地尖叫。真的太夸张了。嗯，就在帕姆脸上露出那个表情后不久，迈克尔就能骑一会儿了，然后他撞车了。他确实撞了。兰迪告诉我们，我们拍了两次这场撞车戏，我们用了史蒂夫的特技替身埃里克·索尔克。那才是真正撞车的人，然后我们做了一些...
some creative editing to have Steve pop up. He said on the first take, we kind of scratched up the bike, but it was still functional and we did a second take. Well, after the scene was over, Phil and Randy called the Wisconsin Trek office to see what they wanted us to do with the bikes. They asked that we return the scratch bike. They picked up the shipping cost, but they gave us permission to gift the other bike to Steve Carell because Steve had been racing bicycles in high school. He was an avid cyclist. He was absolutely so thrilled at the generosity of Trek and Randy sent us a picture of Phil and Randy and Steve when Steve was given the bike. I did not know that Steve was a cyclist. I mean, the man is an onion. He's very sporty.
创意剪辑让史蒂夫跳了出来。他说在第一次拍摄时，我们把自行车刮花了一点，但它还能用，于是我们拍了第二次。嗯，场景结束後，菲尔和兰迪给威斯康星州的崔克办公室打电话，看他们想让我们怎么处理这些自行车。他们要求我们把刮花的自行车退回去。他们承担了运费，但他们允许我们将另一辆自行车送给史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，因为史蒂夫在高中时就参加过自行车比赛。他是个狂热的骑行者。他对崔克的慷慨感到非常激动，兰迪给我们发了一张菲尔、兰迪和史蒂夫在史蒂夫拿到自行车时的合影。我不知道史蒂夫是个骑行者。我的意思是，这个人就像个洋葱。他非常喜欢运动。
The layers just keep coming off. He can play hockey. He's a cyclist. Well, we got a fan mail flurry about Michael's cycling ability. Casey H. from Coral Springs, Florida, plus many others mentioned in double date at Helene's birthday lunch. Michael says he would do a triathlon. He has the running and biking down. He just needs to learn how to swim, but then in Benihana Christmas, he can barely ride his bike into the office and here he crashes into a car. Which one is it? Can he ride a bike or not? Thank you, Casey for pointing out these continuity mysteries. Here's what I want to say. I didn't realize that Steve was an avid cycler and I'm very impressed with his fake bad bike riding now knowing that he really sold it.
他的层层惊喜不断。他会打曲棍球。他是个骑行者。嗯，我们收到了大量关于迈克尔骑行能力的粉丝邮件。来自佛罗里达州科勒尔斯普林斯的凯西·H以及许多其他人提到，在海伦的生日午餐的双重约会中。迈克尔说他会参加铁人三项。他跑步和骑自行车都没问题，他只需要学会游泳，但在《贝尼哈娜的圣诞节》中，他几乎骑不了自行车进办公室，而在这里他撞到了一辆车。到底是哪个？他到底会不会骑自行车？谢谢凯西指出这些连续性谜团。我想说的是，我以前不知道史蒂夫是个狂热的骑行者，现在知道他真的演得很好，我对他的假装骑不好自行车印象深刻。
I mean, and he didn't make a big face. Oh, oh. Oh my gosh. Could you imagine my face if I had to do bad cycling? Please, mine would be horrible too. I would just be like, oh my goodness. This episode is going to start with Jim and Dwight. They've got a big meeting with the chief buyer for Frame Select, Steve Nash. Not the Steve Nash, you know, the amazing point guard played for the Phoenix Suns, Dallas Mavericks, Lakers. He's now the head coach of the Brooklyn Nets. Not that Steve Nash. Angela, Angela. We don't need this description. Stop being a condescending jock hipster. Steve Nash is so cool. I have a location alert. Both the exterior and interior of Frame Select was a building on Alameda Boulevard in Burbank. The office was
我的意思是，他居然没有做那种夸张的表情。哦，哦。哦，天哪。你能想象如果我不得不演骑不好自行车，我会是什么表情吗？拜托，我的表情也会超级糟糕的。我只会觉得，哦，天哪。这一集将从吉姆和德怀特开始。他们与“精选框架”公司的首席买家史蒂夫·纳什有一个重要会议。不是那个史蒂夫·纳什，你知道的，那个为菲尼克斯太阳队、达拉斯小牛队、湖人队效力的神奇控球后卫。他现在是布鲁克林篮网队的主教练。不是那个史蒂夫·纳什。安吉拉，安吉拉。我们不需要这个描述。别做那个居高临下的时髦体育迷了。史蒂夫·纳什太酷了。“精选框架”的外部和内部都是伯班克阿拉米达大道上的一栋建筑。办公室是...
an empty suite that our set decorating crew led by Steve Rothstein had filled up. That big Frame Select logo, I mean, it's very large. It's huge. Over reception. I noticed it. It was designed by Michael Gallenberg and Henry Sain and then built by our construction crew headed by Tim James. I felt like there was a story there. I've never seen us make such a large sign for a company. What does this tell us? Also, Frame Select is very busy. Did you see all the people coming and going? I did. That's what I'm saying. They're a big deal with lots of activity. Well, we have a little bit of Dwight Sass. When they go into the lobby, Dwight tells Jim he should check in with the receptionist because he's good with receptionists. Dwight Sass. But they run
一个由史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦领导的布景装饰团队填满的空套房。那个巨大的“精选框架”标志，我的意思是，它非常大。巨大无比。在接待处上方。我注意到了。它是由迈克尔·加伦伯格和亨利·塞恩设计的，然后由蒂姆·詹姆斯领导的施工团队建造的。我觉得那里有个故事。我从没见过我们为一家公司制作这么大的标志。这说明了什么？此外，“精选框架”非常忙碌。你看到所有进进出出的人了吗？我看到了。这就是我要说的。他们是个有很多活动的大企业。嗯，我们有一点德怀特的傲慢。当他们走进大厅时，德怀特告诉吉姆他应该去和前台登记，因为他很擅长应付前台。德怀特的傲慢。但他们跑...
out of Frame Select. They duck back out of the lobby because Danny Cordray is sitting there. The frickin' Danny Cordray. He is the worst meaning the best salesman ever. He works at Osprey Paper and he keeps taking all of their clients. Well, you know what this means. Oh, I do. It's a guest star alert and it's a big one. It is. Timothy Oliphant, star of Deadwood, star of Justified, also in The Mandalorian, whoo whoo. Plays Danny Cordray. We had a fan question from Natalie F. in San Antonio, Texas. Please tell us everything about working with Timothy Oliphant and how did he come to be on the show? Well, my memory is that Mindy Kaling specifically pitched him for this role and that's how he got the job and it makes sense to me. She
出了“精选框架”。他们又从大厅退了回来，因为丹尼·科德雷正坐在那里。该死的丹尼·科德雷。他绝对是——也就是最好的销售员。他在鱼鹰纸业工作，而且不断抢走他们所有的客户。好吧，你知道这意味着什么。哦，我知道。这是一个客串明星警报，而且是个大咖。确实如此。蒂莫西·奥利芬特，《朽木》的主演，《火线警探》的主演，还在《曼达洛人》里演过，呜呼。饰演丹尼·科德雷。我们有一个来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的娜塔莉·F的粉丝提问。请告诉我们所有关于和蒂莫西·奥利芬特合作的事情，以及他是如何来到这个节目的？嗯，我的记忆是明迪·卡林专门为这个角色推荐了他，这就是他得到这份工作的原因，这对我来说很合情合理。她...
wrote this episode and then later he had a role in the Mindy Project too. So she was a fan. Yeah. I loved working with him. He was so fun. He was so fun. I also was on Conan O'Brien the same night he was a guest and he brought some kind of fancy whiskey we all got to drink. He's a lot of fun. He's great. Yeah. Speaking of Conan, have you heard Conan's podcast interview with him? It's so good, you guys. He is so funny. They're hilarious. When he takes over doing the ads, I was cracking up. That's a good listen, you guys. We reached out to him. He's currently filming Justified in Chicago, the reboot of Justified, but I found an old interview with him where he talked about his time on the office. Oh, yes. They had a whole EPK set up over in the
写了这一集，后来他在《明迪烦事多》里也有一个角色。所以她是个粉丝。是的。我很喜欢和他合作。他太有趣了。他真的很有趣。我还在柯南·奥布莱恩的节目中和他当过同一晚的嘉宾，他带来某种我们都可以喝的高档威士忌。他非常有意思。他太棒了。是的。说到柯南，你听过柯南对他进行的播客采访吗？真的太棒了，伙计们。他太搞笑了。他们太爆笑了。当他接手做广告时，我笑得前仰后合。那是一期很值得听的节目，伙计们。我们联系过他。他目前正在芝加哥拍摄《火线警探》的重启版，但我找到了他的一篇旧采访，他在里面谈到了自己在《办公室》的时光。哦，是的。他们在仓库那边搭了一个完整的EPK（电子新闻包）场景。我记得这个。
warehouse. I remember this. Well, here is Timothy Oliphant talking about how he was excited to be on the show. I wanted to be on it. I've been a fan of the show for forever. When I got that call, it was fantastic. They asked that they wanted me to be on the show. I said, sure. What do I play? I play a character named Danny Cordray. When we meet him, he's a rival salesman who has done quite well. He's a bit of a problem for the guys in the office, the enemy, quote, unquote. To further complicate things, one stated PAM. There seems to be, as the story goes, some discrepancy over whether that didn't work out because of her or that didn't work out because of me. It's quite the subject of conversation. I'm not going to lie. I love the implication
嗯，这里是蒂莫西·奥利芬特谈论他如何为能参演该剧而感到兴奋。我想参演。我一直是这部剧的超级粉丝。当我接到那个电话时，真是太棒了。他们问我是否想参演。我说，当然。我演什么角色？我演一个叫丹尼·科德雷的角色。当我们遇到他时，他是一个非常成功的竞争对手销售员。对办公室里的这群人来说，他是个不小的麻烦，也就是所谓的“敌人”。为了让事情变得更复杂，正如帕姆所说。关于那件事没成功是因为她还是因为我，似乎存在一些分歧。这成了挺热门的话题。我不会撒谎。我喜欢这种暗示。
that perhaps someone of Timothy Oliphant's, what do I say, hotness? Yes, would date me. I was like, I'll take it. Even if he wasn't interested in a second or third date. It made for such a funny dynamic between Jim and PAM. It was so good. Oh, my gosh. Costume contest next week. Oh, yeah. I'll wait. Timothy really fit in right from the beginning. He was just great to work with. This last clip really shows you how he had become part of our family. Really, I just so genuinely flattered that they'd have me and give me an opportunity to do something that's really so different than just about anything I've done. I really feel quite blessed, and it's just been a kick. Rain kind of bugs me. But everyone else, fantastic, been great.
也许蒂莫西·奥利芬特会觉得我很有魅力，该怎么说呢？是的，会愿意和我约会。我想，我接受。即使他对第二次或第三次约会没兴趣。这让吉姆和帕姆之间产生了非常有趣的化学反应。太棒了。噢，天哪。下周有服装比赛。噢，耶。我等着。蒂莫西从一开始就完美融入了剧组。和他合作感觉太棒了。最后一个片段真的向你展示了他是如何成为我们这个大家庭的一员的。说实话，他们能邀请我并给我一个机会，去做一些与我以往做过的几乎所有事情都截然不同的事，我真的感到由衷的受宠若惊。我真的觉得自己很幸运，而且这简直太有趣了。雷恩有点烦我。但其他所有人都太棒了，非常了不起。
I mean, he got it that we dog on rain. You know what I mean? That's when you know you're in, is when you can take a shot at rain. That was very funny. And also, I wasn't expecting it because he was being so sincere. I know. That's why he's so great. We got a fan mail flurry, also Angela, about Danny Cordray's name. People wanted to know if it was inspired by Randy Cordray. It was. Absolutely. We actually reached out to Randy about this, and he said, you might remember that my office was next door to Mindy Kaling. One day in the weeks prior to the script coming out, Mindy came by and said, Randy, you have a cool last name. Can I use it for a character I'm writing? And I said, sure. And that's how Danny Cordray got his name. Randy said
我是说，他懂我们是在拿雷恩开涮。你知道我的意思吗？只有当你能拿雷恩开玩笑时，你才知道自己真正融入了。那段非常搞笑。而且，我一开始没想到会这样，因为他表现得太真诚了。我懂。这就是他为什么这么棒的原因。安吉拉，我们也收到了一波粉丝来信，是关于丹尼·科德雷的名字的。大家想知道这个名字是不是灵感来源于兰迪·科德雷。是的。完全是。我们其实就这件事联系了兰迪，他说，你可能还记得我的办公室就在明迪·卡灵隔壁。就在剧本出炉前几周的某天，明迪顺道过来对我说，兰迪，你的姓氏真酷。我能用它来给我正在创作的一个角色吗？我说，当然可以。丹尼·科德雷就是这样得来的名字。兰迪说
he was really flattered to have someone as cool as Timothy Oliphant having his own last name on the show. And he says people still come up to him and say, you know, there's a character in the office that has your last name. Oh, that's amazing. Back at the office, Andy is starting to spiral. We mentioned this earlier. He's gotten his Cornell alumni magazine and has learned that Broccoli Rob has this milk commercial that he's singing in. And Andy can't take it. Andy was the musical one. He had more solos than Broccoli Rob. And now Broccoli Rob has a commercial. Listen, not only that, he's collaborating with Trey Anastasio, the guitarist from Fish. Oh, yeah. And there's a quote about how great that collaboration was. I mean, he doesn't know what
能让像蒂莫西·奥利芬特这么酷的人在剧中使用和自己一样的姓氏，他感到非常受宠若惊。他说现在还有人会跑来对他说，你知道办公室里有个角色的姓氏和你一样吗。哦，太神奇了。回到办公室，安迪开始情绪失控了。我们之前提到过这一点。他收到了康奈尔大学的校友杂志，并得知西兰花罗布（Broccoli Rob）拍了一支唱歌的牛奶广告。安迪简直要崩溃了。安迪才是玩音乐的那个。他的独唱比西兰花罗布多。现在西兰花罗布却拍了广告。听着，不仅如此，他还和飞鱼乐队（Phish）的吉他手特雷·阿纳斯塔西奥（Trey Anastasio）合作了。哦，是的。杂志上还有一段引言，盛赞这次合作有多么出色。我是说，他简直不知道该拿自己怎么办了。
to do with himself. We had a fan question from Anne S. in Zurich, Switzerland. Hello, Anne from Zurich. This question traveled a long way. When Andy is reading the Cornell alumni magazine, Cornell is written in purple. It seems very odd for a school magazine to not be in the school colors. Did you have to do this for copyright reasons? What a smart catch. I asked Randy, he said that was a real Cornell alumni magazine that Phil Shea got a real one. And I looked it up and sometimes they print the name in purple. Don't know why. Don't know why. But it was real. It's a Cornell mystery. I know someone from Cornell. If you know, let us know. Why sometimes purple? Is it a secondary color? I don't know what that means.
我们收到了来自瑞士苏黎世安·S的粉丝提问。你好，苏黎世的安。这个问题跨越了很长的距离。当安迪在读康奈尔大学校友杂志时，“Cornell”这个词是用紫色印刷的。学校杂志居然不用学校的代表色，这看起来真的很奇怪。你们这么做是因为版权原因吗？真是个精妙的问题。我问过兰迪，他说那是真正的康奈尔校友杂志，菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）弄到了一本真的。我查了一下，他们有时确实会用紫色印刷校名。不知道为什么。不知道为什么。但这确实是真的。这是一个康奈尔之谜。我认识一个康奈尔的人。如果你知道原因，请告诉我们。为什么有时会是紫色？这算是一种辅助色吗？我不知道那是什么意思。
Well, like sometimes in sports, you have like the Team Jersey, they'll have their home version, they'll have their away version, and then they'll have a specialty one. Guess who's son got really into all of the home and away and specialty jerseys of every major sports team for a period of time? Your son. Yes, this was after his hidden logo. I love that he learns all of that. Our son just got really into Legolas from Lord of the Rings and just wanted all of the elf wigs we could purchase. We had a bin of wigs by the front door. I would come home. He'd be Legolas in the front yard. Why do you need multiple wigs? Sometimes Legolas had braids. Oh, I didn't know that. Sometimes it was just down. Oh, yeah, I didn't realize. Yeah, we had a few options for Legolas.
嗯，就像有时候在体育运动中，球队的球衣会有主场版、客场版，然后还会有一款特别版。你猜谁的儿子有一段时间对所有主要体育球队的主场、客场和特别版球衣都疯狂痴迷？你的儿子。是的，这发生在他迷上隐藏标志之后。我喜欢他把这些都搞得一清二楚。我们的儿子最近疯狂迷上了《指环王》里的莱格拉斯，想要我们能买到的所有精灵假发。我们在前门放了一个装假发的箱子。我回到家。他会在前院扮演莱格拉斯。你为什么需要好几顶假发？有时候莱格拉斯的假发有辫子。哦，我不知道。有时候是披肩发。哦，是的，我没意识到。对，我们有几种不同的莱格拉斯造型可选。
It depends if it's like a formal event. Thank you. Thank you, Sam. Oh, see, I can tell you all about the jerseys and you can tell me about this guy's hair. It doesn't seem quite the same. I mean, I don't know. This is knowledge we have. This is knowledge we have. Speaking of fan mail, we got this really interesting letter from Sarah L in Ontario, Canada. Here's what Sarah said. In this episode, Andy hears of the success of his old buddy Robert Broccoli Rob. Sarah points out there are a lot of Roberts on the office. We use this name a lot. We have Bob Vance, who by the way was played by Bobby Ray Schaefer. We also have Robert Dunder, Robert Mifflin. Upcoming, we have Robert California and Senator Robert Lipton. That is a lot. We really liked that name. Sarah went on to say that
这取决于是不是正式活动。谢谢。谢谢你，萨姆。哦，你看，我可以跟你讲所有关于球衣的事，而你却可以跟我讲这个男人的头发。感觉好像不太一样。我是说，我不知道。这是我们掌握的知识。这是我们掌握的知识。说到粉丝来信，我们收到了加拿大安大略省萨拉·L发来的一封非常有趣的信。萨拉是这么说的。在这集里，安迪听说了他的老朋友罗伯特·“西兰花”·罗布的成功。萨拉指出，《办公室》里有很多叫罗伯特的角色。我们经常用这个名字。我们有鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance），顺便说一句，他由鲍比·雷·谢弗（Bobby Ray Schaefer）饰演。我们还有罗伯特·邓德（Robert Dunder）、罗伯特·米夫林（Robert Mifflin）。接下来，我们还有罗伯特·加利福尼亚（Robert California）和参议员罗伯特·利普顿（Robert Lipton）。真的有好多。我们真的很喜欢这个名字。萨拉接着说
according to babycenter.com, the name Robert means bright fame. And it peaked in popularity in the United States in the 1930s and 40s, which totally makes sense for Robert Dunder and Robert Mifflin. But you know, I guess our writers, it peaked in popularity with our writers. I had not even realized. Me either. Sarah, thank you. You did a sort of like a little, a little, a little, a mini Dr. Tibbadoe. Yeah, a mini Dr. Tibbadoe. Yeah. Lady, we haven't mentioned Jim and Pam's talking head about Danny Cordray. They're very, did you find it like a little tense? I mean, I thought it was so fun. I love that Pam goes, you know, I have a baby with you. Yeah. But here's this dynamic we don't see often where Jim is a little
根据 babycenter.com 的数据，“Robert”这个名字的意思是“辉煌的名声”。它在美国的流行度在 20 世纪 30 和 40 年代达到顶峰，这对于罗伯特·邓德和罗伯特·米夫林来说完全说得通。但你知道，我猜我们的编剧们，这个名字在我们编剧中的流行度也达到了顶峰。我甚至都没有意识到。我也是。萨拉，谢谢你。你刚才有点像个小型的、小型的、微型的蒂巴多医生。对，微型的蒂巴多医生。对。天哪，我们还没提到吉姆和帕姆关于丹尼·科德雷的访谈呢。他们俩，你觉得是不是有点紧张？我是说，我觉得挺有趣的。我喜欢帕姆说，你知道的，我和你有个孩子。对。但这里出现了一种我们不常见的动态，那就是吉姆被某个人弄得有点
rattled by someone. Yeah. Yeah, it's like the Charles Miner thing. Well, I guess there's some controversy over who dumped who or who fizzled who. Yeah. Pam seems to think he wasn't interested, but Danny says it was the other way around. We're going to find out next week. Well, back at frame select Dwight and Jim are going to have to walk into the lobby where Danny is sitting. And Dwight thinks that the best way to intimidate Danny is to talk about having gotten tickets with his date to a penis museum. A thousand dollars. That's how much it costs. Those were the tickets. Well, we got a fan question from Colleen M. in Louisville, Kentucky, who said Dwight tries to impress Danny by having a fake conversation about a large penis he saw at the penis museum
心神不宁。对。对，就像查尔斯·迈纳（Charles Miner）那次一样。好吧，关于是谁甩了谁或者是谁不了了之，似乎存在一些争议。对。帕姆似乎认为他对她没兴趣，但丹尼却说情况正好相反。我们下周就会知道了。好了，镜头回到框架精选（Frame Select），德怀特和吉姆不得不走进丹尼坐着的大厅。德怀特认为恐吓丹尼的最佳方式是谈论他和女伴买到了去阴茎博物馆的门票。一千美元。这就是票价。这些就是门票。嗯，我们收到了来自肯塔基州路易斯维尔的柯林·M的粉丝提问，她说德怀特试图通过编造一段关于他在阴茎博物馆看到的大阴茎的对话来给丹尼留下深刻印象，
where tickets are a thousand dollars. Well, this line stuck out to me because I've been to this museum. Oh my gosh. It's called the Icelandic phallological museum. And it is an entire museum dedicated to penises. Tickets are really less than $20. So I just wanted to say Dwight really overpaid. Well, Colleen, I looked up this museum. I can't believe you've been there. No. It is in Reykjavík in Iceland. Oh my God. And you guys, she is right. It contains a collection of phallic specimens of more than 200 penises in penile parts. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Are they real? Yes, belonging to land and sea mammals of Iceland. There's also 55 specimens belonging to 16 different kinds of whale. One specimen from a rogue polar bear. 36 specimens belonging to seven
那里的门票要一千美元。嗯，这句台词特别触动我，因为我去过这个博物馆。噢，天哪。它叫做冰岛阴茎博物馆（The Icelandic Phallological Museum）。这是一个专门展示阴茎的博物馆。门票其实还不到 20 美元。所以我只是想说，德怀特真的是花冤枉钱了。嗯，柯林，我查了一下这个博物馆。我真不敢相信你去过那里。没有。它位于冰岛的雷克雅未克。哦，天哪。各位，她是对的。那里收藏了 200 多根阴茎及阴茎部位的阴茎标本。等等，等等，等等，等等。它们是真的吗？是的，属于冰岛的陆地和海洋哺乳动物。其中还有来自 16 种不同鲸鱼的 55 个标本。一个来自流浪北极熊的标本。36 个标本属于 7 种
different kinds of seal and walrus. There's some images. I can't get out of my mind. I want you to know because I looked at the gallery. Also, here's the thing, here's the thing that kind of cracked me up. According to their website, and it's true if you look at the gallery, in addition to the biological section of the museum, which is a bunch of penises and jars, visitors can also view a collection of about 350 artistic oddments and practical utensils related to the museum's chosen theme. When they say practical utensils related to the museum's chosen theme, I saw what looked like to be a wooden cheeseboard with a giant penis coming off of it that held containers. And Colleen is right. It is 2,500 Icelandic krona, which equals roughly
不同种类的海豹和海象。有些画面。我脑子里挥之不去。我想让你们知道，因为我看了图库。另外，还有一件事，有一件事让我觉得挺搞笑的。根据他们的网站，如果你看了图库，事实也确实如此，除了博物馆的生物学部分（里面是一堆泡在罐子里的阴茎）之外，访客还可以参观大约 350 件与博物馆选定主题相关的艺术奇珍和实用器具。当他们说“与博物馆选定主题相关的实用器具”时，我看到了一块看起来像是木制奶酪板的东西，上面长着一个巨大的阴茎，用来固定容器。柯林说得对。门票是 2500 冰岛克朗，折合美元大约是
$18.41 in the United States. And children under the age of 13 get in for free. I mean, you can go to their website. If you Google Penis Museum, the first thing that comes up is the Icelandic phallological museum. Am I saying that right? Phallological? I don't know. Phallological. I mean phallic, phallological. Yeah, phallological. There's a lot of penises there, you guys, that you can see.
18.41 美元。13 岁以下的儿童可以免费入场。我是说，你可以去他们的网站看看。如果你在谷歌上搜索“阴茎博物馆”，弹出的第一个结果就是冰岛阴茎博物馆。我没说错吧？Phallological（阴茎学）？我不知道。Phallological。我是说 phallic（阴茎的）、phallological。对，phallological。那里有很多阴茎，各位，你们可以去参观。
But mostly of marine life. There's some kind of land mammals as well. There's 20 different kinds of land mammals. No, a human. Are there any preserved human penises? There's a few homo sapiens. There's some folklore specimens. Overall, it contains 282 specimens from 93 different species of animals. And you can get a cheeseboard with a giant dick coming off of it.
但主要都是海洋生物的。也有一些陆地哺乳动物的。有 20 种不同的陆地哺乳动物。不对，有人类的吗？有没有保存完好的人类阴茎？有几个智人的。还有一些民间传说的标本。总体而言，它包含了来自 93 种不同动物的 282 个标本。而且你还可以买到一块长着巨根的奶酪板。
But who conceived of this museum? Who pitched it? Who funded it? The founder is a historian with a BA degree from the University of Iceland and an MLIT degree in Latin American history from the University of Edinburgh, Scotland. His name is, I'm going to spell it for you. Okay. It's S-I-G-U-R-O-U-R. I think if I'm reading this correctly, his last name is H-J-A-R-T-A-R-S-O-N. Okay.
但是，是谁构思了这座博物馆？是谁提出了这个点子？是谁资助的？创始人是一位历史学家，拥有冰岛大学的文学学士学位，以及苏格兰爱丁堡大学拉丁美洲历史的文学硕士学位。他的名字是，我来拼给你们听。好的。是 S-I-G-U-R-O-U-R。如果我没读错的话，他的姓氏是 H-J-A-R-T-A-R-S-O-N。好的。
Okay. I was not sure how to say that. That's fine. On the website, if you go to the website, he writes about how this all came to be. In the founder's own words, it says, the foundation was laid in 1974 when I got a pistol or a bull's penis. Just got it. Received that. Received that.
好吧。我不太确定这个怎么读。没关系。在网站上，如果你访问他们的网站，他会写到这一切是如何诞生的。用创始人的原话来说，基金会奠基於 1974 年，当时我得到了一根公牛的阴茎或称皮鞭。刚拿到。收到了这个。收到了那个。
As a child, I was sent into the countryside during summer vacations and there I was given a pistol as a whip for the animals. So he could whip the other animals with a bull's penis. Could be standard. I don't know. Some of my teachers used to work in summer in a nearby whaling station and after the first specimen, they started bringing me whale penises. Oh my gosh.
小时候，我暑假被送到乡下，在那里我得到了一根牛鞭用来赶动物。所以他可以用公牛的阴茎来抽打其他动物？这可能是标准做法。我不知道。我的一些老师以前在附近的一个捕鲸站做暑期工，在第一个标本之后，他们开始给我带鲸鱼阴茎。噢，天哪。
It's like this was thrust upon him. He didn't even seek it out. The penises found him. The penises found him. Then he says the idea came gradually that it might be interesting collecting specimens from more mammalian species. By 1980, I had 13 specimens, four from whales and nine from land animals. It goes on and on and on, you guys, as he collected.
感觉这一切就像是强加在他身上的。他甚至都没有主动去寻找。阴茎找到了他。阴茎找到了他。然后他说，收集更多哺乳动物标本的想法是逐渐产生的。到 1980 年，我有了 13 个标本，其中 4 个来自鲸鱼，9 个来自陆地动物。就这样一直持续下去，各位，随着他不断收集，
The museum was formed and they even have honorary members of the museum. All I'm thinking right now is how grateful I am that my son collects flags from different countries. Well, there's that. Yes. And you know what? I'm sure from a biological standpoint, they have learned a lot by all of the penis in the jars. And if you want to go see them and get a cheese board with a penis that also holds glasses,
博物馆成立了，他们甚至还有博物馆的名誉会员。我现在满脑子想的都是，我很庆幸我的儿子收集的是不同国家的国旗。嗯，也是。是的。而且你知道吗？我确信从生物学的角度来看，通过罐子里所有的阴茎，他们已经学到了很多东西。如果你想去看看它们，并买一个带阴茎的奶酪板（同时还能放杯子），
Sam has already put it on his Christmas list. I've always wanted to go to Iceland. Me too. It's on my list. I've heard Rekiavac is amazing. I will probably now go to this museum. I know you will. Angela, thank you.
萨姆已经把它加入他的圣诞愿望清单了。我一直想去冰岛。我也是。它在我的愿望清单上。我听说雷克雅未克棒极了。我现在可能会去参观这个博物馆。我知道你会去的。安吉拉，谢谢你。
You're welcome. From the bottom of my heart. Thank you, Colleen. Well, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Michael is going to get a phone call in the middle of his conference room meeting. Yeah. Jim and Dwight are freaked out. Yeah, they're calling in Michael for backup.
不客气。发自内心地谢谢你。谢谢你，柯林。嗯，我觉得我们该休息一下了，因为当我们回来时，迈克尔将在他的会议室会议开到一半时接到一个电话。对。吉姆和德怀特吓坏了。对，他们正叫迈克尔去支援。
And I have a deleted scene that really shows why they got so in their head. Well, we're back. Danny is not impressed by Dwight's penis museum tickets. They ask him what he's doing there. And he's like, I'm just here for the coffee. He's so smooth. I know Dwight's like, no, you're not. Dwight gets so pissed off.
我还有一个删减片段，真正展示了他们为什么会这么胡思乱想。好了，我们回来了。丹尼对德怀特阴茎博物馆的门票毫无印象。他们问他在那里做什么。他说，我只是来喝杯咖啡的。他太圆滑了。我知道德怀特心想，才怪，你才不是。德怀特气疯了。
And Jim is like, you can just tell Jim wants to hide under the table. The scene would have continued and I'm going to play the deleted scene because it really shows you how in Dwight and Jim's head Danny was getting because everything just falls in this guy's lap. Everything. Listen to this. Hey, by the way, did you open that restaurant? Last time I saw you, you were talking about that.
而吉姆则是一副恨不得钻到桌子底下的表情。这个场景本来会继续下去，我要播放这个删减片段，因为它真正向你展示了丹尼是如何一步步进入德怀特和吉姆的脑海的，因为所有好事都落在这个家伙头上了。所有好事。听听这个。嘿，顺便问一下，你那家餐厅开业了吗？我上次见你的时候，你还在聊那个呢。
Yeah, and I did. It was embarrassing. Really? You went under? My dad and I are about to open and we get this insane highball offer from this developer. He wants to build these huge lofts and I think he's great, you know, because my dad can finally just retire and take it easy. And then of course, what does he do?
对，我开了。真丢脸。真的吗？你破产了？我和我爸正准备开业，结果一个开发商给我们开出了一个极其诱人的高价收购要约。他想建这些巨大的阁楼，我觉得这挺棒的，你知道的，因为我爸终于可以退休享清福了。然后当然啦，他做了什么？
Travels the world, but I guess that's just the cowboy in them. Sorry, what was embarrassing? Excuse me? You said the story was embarrassing, but that just sounds wonderful. Yeah, I guess I was just kind of embarrassed that, you know, I got so much out of it for such a little effort. Mr. Courgette, he's ready for you. All right.
周游世界，不过我猜这就是他身上的牛仔精神吧。抱歉，有什么好丢脸的？不好意思？你说这个故事很丢脸，但这听起来棒极了。对，我想我只是有点尴尬，你知道的，我没费多大劲就从中得到了这么多好处。柯尔杰先生，他准备好见你了。好的。
Well, guys, wish me luck. Good luck. Oh my gosh, I'm just embarrassed. I got so much out of it for so little effort. Yeah, just made a ton of money not doing anything. All right, guys, wish me luck. And twice, like the minute Danny like turns the corner Dwight makes that noise. Well, apparently the only choice they have is to call Michael.
好吧，伙计们，祝我好运。祝你好运。哦，天哪，我只是觉得很尴尬。我没花什么力气就得到了这么多好处。对啊，什么都没干就赚了一大笔钱。好了，伙计们，祝我好运。就在丹尼转过拐角的瞬间，德怀特发出了那种声音。好吧，他们唯一的选择显然就是找迈克尔。
Yeah, he's in the middle of a quarterly crisis mode meeting and he is eager to leave. People are like, what are you doing? He's so thrilled they called him. He's so excited. Well, this phone call between Michael and Jim was shot on completely different days. When we shot the conference room part, John stood off camera and set his lines. And when we did the part at frame select, Steve was off camera saying his lines.
对，他正处于季度危机模式会议的中间，而且他迫不及待地想离开。大家都在问，你在干什么？他们叫他去，他兴奋极了。他太激动了。嗯，迈克尔和吉姆之间的这通电话是在完全不同的日子拍摄的。当我们拍摄会议室部分时，约翰站在镜头外说出他的台词。而当我们拍摄帧选那部分时，史蒂夫站在镜头外说他的台词。
They were never actually talking on the phone together. Little fun fact. Little TV magic. Up next, we have Andy stopping by Daryl's office. Daryl has glasses. I saw. I thought it was so cute. In the script, the stage direction for Daryl's glasses was this.
他们其实从来没有真正在电话里交谈过。一个小趣闻。小小的电视魔法。接下来，我们看到安迪顺道拜访了达瑞尔的办公室。达瑞尔戴着眼镜。我看到了。我觉得太可爱了。在剧本中，关于达瑞尔眼镜的舞台指示是这样的：
Andy knocks on Daryl's door and enters. Daryl has his reading glasses on the kind you get from Barnes & Noble. Oh, the little readers at the kiosk. Yeah, I love that detail. That's adorable. Well, I guess Daryl is so busy because he's entering his points on his Weight Watchers website. Yeah. Randy said this was a big deal to clear Weight Watchers.
安迪敲敲达瑞尔的门并走了进去。达瑞尔戴着老花镜，就是那种你在巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）买得到的。哦，柜台上的那种小老花镜。对，我喜欢这个细节。太可爱了。好吧，我猜达瑞尔太忙了，因为他正在体重管理网（Weight Watchers）的网站上输入他的积分。对。兰迪说，要获准出现 Weight Watchers 可是件大事。
Oh, yeah. He said NBC sales originally said no because they were in the process of negotiating a quote integration deal with another NBC series. And integration deal is where a company like Weight Watchers or Staples will actually pay the network an amount of money to mention their product on the air, where it's not a coincidence. I guess our sales department didn't want us to give away a mention for free because they thought it might undercut their ability to negotiate for the other show. Oh, Randy said there was a quote flurry of emails between us and sales and eventually
哦，是的。他说 NBC 销售部门最初拒绝了，因为他们正在与另一部 NBC 系列剧协商一项所谓的整合协议。而整合协议是指像 Weight Watchers 或 Staples 这样的公司，会实际支付给电视网一笔钱，以便在节目中提及他们的产品，这并不是巧合。我猜我们的销售部门不想让我们免费送出一个提及名额，因为他们认为这可能会削弱他们为另一部剧谈判的能力。哦，兰迪说我们和销售部门之间有一阵“邮件狂潮”，最终
they said, fine, you can mention it, but only this one time. And now you're on our list. I guess so. Oh my goodness. Well, Andy is stopping by to talk to Daryl because he wants to start a band and he needs Daryl on the keys. He offers him $60 a session. And Daryl's like, that's crazy.
他们说，好吧，你们可以提一次，但仅此一次。现在你们上了我们的黑名单了。我猜是吧。噢，天哪。好吧，安迪顺道来找达瑞尔是因为他想组建一个乐队，他需要达瑞尔负责键盘。他开价一节课 60 美元。而达瑞尔说，这也太疯狂了。
I'll do it for $40. I loved that. I know. Back at frame select, Michael has joined Jim and Dwight. Danny's going to note three salesmen for one sale, huh? Well, Michael likes to call it overkill. Yeah. But he doesn't want to give away our secrets. He doesn't.
我 40 美元就干。我喜欢这个。我知道。回到帧选，迈克尔加入了吉姆和德怀特。丹尼会注意到三个销售员只为了做成一单，对吧？嗯，迈克尔喜欢称之为“大材小用”。对。但他不想泄露我们的秘密。他才不想呢。
I loved that line. I thought that was really clever. I found that charming of Michael. Well, Michael can't get past this one little thing. It's not Adam. He thinks he knows Danny as a model. Yeah, he's like, that guy's a male model. Yeah.
我喜欢那句台词。我觉得那真的非常巧妙。我觉得迈克尔这样很有魅力。嗯，迈克尔对这件小事怎么也过不去。不是亚当。他觉得他认识丹尼，觉得他是当模特的。对，他就像是在说，那家伙是个男模。对。
And you're sort of thinking like, oh, he's just saying that because he's so handsome. Exactly. Well, there was a deleted scene where Michael finally remembers where he knows him. You'll never guess what Danny modeled. He was, in fact, a model. Oh my god. Jansbord Backpacks. 10 or 15 years ago, you were a model for Jansbord Backpacks.
你可能会想，哦，他这么说只是因为对方太帅了。完全正确。有一个删减片段是迈克尔终于想起来他在哪里认识丹尼了。你永远猜不到丹尼当过什么模特。他其实是一个模特。哦，天哪。詹斯波特背包（Jansport Backpacks）。10 或 15 年前，你是詹斯波特背包的模特。
Were you not? Yes. Yeah. But what's going on here? I knew it. I remember the one you were like, hey. Oh my gosh. Uh-huh. And the storyline continues.
难道不是吗？是的。是的。但这里是怎么回事？我就知道。我记得其中一幅广告，你会说，嘿。哦，天哪。呃-huh。故事还在继续。
Michael later finding the backpack ad online. He went on his computer. He pulled it up. There is a photo of Danny with the backpack. It's so great. It's in deleted scenes. But guess what? Randy shared with us that Michael Gallenberg shot this photo on green screen.
迈克尔后来在网上找到了那个背包广告。他打开电脑，调出了那个网页。上面有一张丹尼背着背包的照片。太棒了。这在删减片段里。但你猜怎么着？兰迪跟我们分享说，迈克尔·盖伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）是在绿幕前拍这张照片的。
Henry saying Photoshop the image into purchased stock backgrounds from Getty Images. Henry also built the fakey web page for it. And Randy gave us the full resolution image of the backpack photo shoot. They are amazing. I'm going to put them in Office Laves Pod Stories. But imagine with me, Timothy Oliphant as Danny, giving a very moody, kind of sassy glance over his shoulder as he has a backpack on. The photos are amazing.
亨利说把图像用Photoshop合成到从盖蒂图片社（Getty Images）购买的现成背景中去。亨利还为它制作了一个虚假的网页。兰迪给了我们背包照片的高分辨率原图。它们太棒了。我要把它们发到《办公室迷恋》播客故事里。但请和我一起想象一下，蒂莫西·奥利芬特饰演的丹尼，背着背包，转过头来，深情而又有点俏皮地瞥了一眼。这些照片太棒了。
I feel like Danny Cordray is everything Michael wishes he could be. I mean. Male model. Jansport male model. Yeah. Top salesperson. Well, when Michael and Jim and Dwight go in to meet with Steve Nash, they really pitch him hard.
我觉得丹尼·科德雷就是迈克尔梦寐以求的所有样子的集合。我是说。男模。詹斯波特男模。对。顶级销售员。嗯，当迈克尔、吉姆和德怀特进去和史蒂夫·纳什（Steve Nash）会面时，他们真的极力向他推销。
They say we will deliver on the weekends. We'll give you all of our paper at cost. He's like, shake my hand. Shake my hand now. And even still, Steve Nash is going to go with Danny Cordray. Michael can't believe it. Guest to our alert, Steve Nash was played by Pete Pasteur. He has appeared on Seinfeld, Chicago Hope and Passions.
他们说我们周末也能交货。我们把所有的纸张都以成本价卖给你。他却说：握手。现在就跟我握手。即便如此，史蒂夫·纳什还是要选丹尼·科德雷。迈克尔简直不敢相信。嘉宾出场提醒，史蒂夫·纳什由皮特·帕斯特尔（Pete Pasteur）饰演。他曾出演过《宋飞正传》（Seinfeld）、《芝加哥希望》（Chicago Hope）和《激情》（Passions）。
Not interested in Michael Steele. Well, the guys are really frustrated now. They're going to leave frames select. Dwight blames Jim. Michael says they just simply got busted. They're going to get in the elevators, kind of dejected and go home. We had a fan question from Anu Yu in Estonia and Charis D from West Wales, UK and others.
对迈克尔的钢铁推销毫无兴趣。好吧，这几个家伙现在真的很沮丧。他们要离开帧选了。德怀特责怪吉姆。迈克尔则说他们只是单纯被抓包了。他们走进电梯，一副沮丧的样子准备回家。我们收到了来自爱沙尼亚的 Anu Yu、英国西威尔士的 Charis D 以及其他人的粉丝提问。
Was it scripted or improv at seven minutes and 45 seconds when Michael says, why is there a door close button if it doesn't even close the door? That was scripted. And I did a deep dive on door close buttons. What? Have you ever wondered about the door close button? Like, does it really close the door on elevators?
7分45秒时，当迈克尔说“如果关门按钮根本不能关门，那它到底为什么还要存在？”时，那是剧本写的还是即兴发挥？那是剧本写的。我深入研究了电梯关门按钮。什么？你从来没有对电梯关门按钮产生过疑问吗？比如，它真的能关上电梯门吗？
Does it really work? I have never wondered about this. Well, I had this faint memory of this story coming out years ago that said door close buttons don't work. Oh. So I looked into it. Did the door open buttons work? Door open buttons work.
它真的有用吗？我从来没有想过这个问题。好吧，我依稀记得几年前流传过这样一个故事，说电梯关门按钮其实根本不管用。哦。所以我查了一下。那开门按钮管用吗？开门按钮是管用的。
Door close ones are just to fake us out so we feel like we're getting somewhere because we're in a hurry. That's exactly right, Angela. Come on. The New York Times did a piece on door close buttons. Here's the scoop. This is a mom detective moment. I'm so proud of myself.
关门按钮只是用来糊弄我们的，让我们因为赶时间而觉得正在取得进展。完全正确，安吉拉。拜托。《纽约时报》曾专门报道过电梯关门按钮。内幕是这样的。这是一个妈妈侦探的高光时刻。我为自己感到骄傲。
All I did was look up an article. I mean, someone else figured it out. Most elevator door buttons do not work. In 1990, we passed the Americans with Disabilities Act. Okay? Part of that legislation required that elevator doors remain open long enough for anyone who might be using crutches, a cane, or a wheelchair
我所做的只是查了一篇文章。我是说，别人已经把这事弄明白了。大多数电梯关门按钮根本不管用。1990 年，我们通过了《美国残疾人法案》（Americans with Disabilities Act）。好吧？该立法的一部分要求电梯门必须保持开启足够长的时间，以便任何可能使用拐杖、手杖或轮椅的人
to enter and exit. And as a result, door close buttons were phased out. They used to work. But after this legislation was passed, they did away with them. But they left the button? Yes, because that way they could be operated by firefighters or maintenance workers in the case of an emergency,
能够进出。因此，关门按钮就被逐渐淘汰了。它们以前确实管用。但在这项立法通过后，他们就废除了这个功能。但他们把按钮留下了？对，因为这样一来，消防员或维修工人在紧急情况下就可以用它们操作，
but they only work if you have a proper key or a code. Huh. Yeah. So none of the door close buttons work in any elevators unless you have a proper key or a code. That's right. Am I understanding this correctly? Yes. So I can tell my kids to quit hitting it over and over?
但它们只有在你拥有正确的钥匙或密码时才起作用。哈。对。所以没有任何一部电梯里的关门按钮是管用的，除非你有正确的钥匙或密码。就是这样。我理解得没错吧？是的。所以我可以告诉我的孩子们别再一直狂按它了吗？
That's right. Okay. But that's not all. Okay. The article also covered crosswalk signals. You know, the button that you press to cross the street? Yeah, you're kind of obsessed with them. We were on a walk the other day and you're like,
没错。好吧。但这还不是全部。好吧。那篇文章还讨论了人行横道信号灯。你知道过马路时按的那个按钮吗？对，你对它们有点着迷。我们前几天散步的时候，你还说，
hmm, you were like suspect of one of them. Well, it had a sign that said, don't press. I know. I was like, what's this about? Yeah. In 2004, New York City deactivated most of the pedestrian buttons. So of the over 3,000 walk buttons in New York City, more than 2,500 of them were replaced with placebos.
嗯，你当时对其中一个产生怀疑。好吧，它上面有个标志写着“请勿按压”。我知道。我当时想，这是怎么回事？对。2004 年，纽约市停用了绝大多数行人按钮。因此，在纽约市的 3000 多个行人通行按钮中，有 2500 多个被替换成了安慰剂。
They're just there to give the illusion of control. Today, there are only 120 working walk systems controlled by the pedestrian. Why not just get rid of them? I don't need your fake button. Just get rid of it. I don't know. But in 2010, ABC News did a study of pedestrian crosswalks
它们只是为了给人一种掌控感的错觉。如今，只有 120 个由行人控制的真正起作用的通行系统。为什么不干脆把它们拆了？我不需要你这种假按钮。干脆拆了得了。我不知道。但在 2010 年，美国广播公司新闻（ABC News）对
in Austin, Texas, Gainesville, Florida, and Syracuse, and only one of the signals was actually pedestrian controlled. So I mean, it's not just New York City. Yeah. But then I found an article that was written by an engineer who said that pushing the crosswalk button does have an effect. But it's not the effect you might think. He said most crosswalks are computer controlled,
德克萨斯州奥斯汀、佛罗里达州盖恩斯维尔和锡拉丘兹的行人过街人行横道进行了研究，发现其中只有一个信号灯实际上是由行人控制的。所以我的意思是，这不仅仅是纽约市的问题。对。但后来我发现了一位工程师写的一篇文章，他说按下人行横道按钮确实会产生效果。但它产生的效果可能和你想象的不一样。他说大多数人行横道都是由电脑控制的，
and it's all about traffic, traffic maintenance and control. And he said pressing the crosswalk button will not make the light change faster. But what it will do is extend the amount of time that you can cross the street. So when it's automatic, there's a certain amount of time allotted for that crosswalk. But if the button is activated, it will stay on longer.
这一切都与交通、交通维护和控制有关。他说按下人行横道按钮并不会让红绿灯变变得更快。但它能做的是延长你过马路的时间。所以当它是自动时，该人行横道会分配一定的时间。但如果按下了按钮，绿灯就会亮得更久。
So you can get across the street without running. Exactly. What about that intersection by my house where the light rarely turns? And so I pull forward and pull back and pull forward and pull back over the crosswalk. Does that do anything? Yeah, right.
这样你就可以不用一路小跑地过马路了。完全正确。那我家里附近那个红绿灯很少变绿的路口呢？所以我总是把车往前开一点，再倒退一点，再往前开一点，再倒退一点，压过人行横道。那样会有用吗？对啊。
There's that rumor that there's some sort of, I mean, when you say it out loud, it sounds ridiculous, right? That there's some sort of like magnetic sensor underneath the ground. Uh-huh. That makes lights change. Yeah. I mean, what do you think, just when we say it?
有那种传言说，某种——大声说出来的话，听起来很荒谬，对吧？——地下有什么磁性传感器。呃-huh。能让红绿灯改变。对。我是说，你觉得呢，就凭我们说出来的这些？
Based on all we know now about the buttons. Do we think that's real? When you say it out loud, it sounds like it doesn't work. I mean, what I've done before, when I've gotten to one of those places where it like never changes because... And by the way, this is an intersection that has like no one there.
根据我们现在对这些按钮的全部了解。我们觉得那是真的吗？当你大声说出来时，听起来就像是根本不管用。我是说，我以前做过的事是，当开到那些因为某种原因从不变换红绿灯的地方时……顺便说一句，那是一个几乎空无一人的路口。
I know. That's why it doesn't change. Yeah. What I've done before is I've gotten out of the car and pressed the crosswalk button. I've done that too. And now I realize that I'm doing nothing. I know.
我知道。这就是为什么它不亮。对。我以前做过的事是下车去按人行横道按钮。我也做过。现在我意识到我什么都没做。我知道。
I've done that too. Well, there you go. Well, that was fascinating. The article went on to say that we need these fake buttons. Why? We need the illusion of control. It's good for us. Oh my gosh.
我也做过。好吧，原来如此。好吧，这太迷人了。那篇文章接着说，我们需要这些假按钮。为什么？我们需要掌控感的错觉。这对我们有好处。噢，天哪。
What is this, an episode of Westworld? Listen, the article had a third category and I didn't know if I should bring it up, but it's about office thermostats. None of them work. They're controlled by some master thing. Most buildings, master thermostats, are controlled by a master grid somewhere not accessible.
这算什么，一集《西部世界》（Westworld）吗？听着，这篇文章还有第三类，我不知道该不该提，但它是关于办公室温控器的。它们全都不管用。它们是由某个主控系统控制的。大多数建筑的主温控器都是由某个无法接近的中央网络控制的。
And then the office you rent, they'll put like a fakey box in your office. Like they found that like 85% of them were fake and they gave workers the illusion that they could control if they were hot and cold and they found people complained less. What the hell? And so buildings had like the fake controls in the offices
然后你租的办公室里，他们会装一个像假的控制盒一样的东西。比如他们发现大约 85% 的温控器都是假的，这给员工营造了一种错觉，让他们以为自己能控制冷热，结果他们发现员工抱怨得更少了。搞什么鬼？所以大楼在办公室里装了假控制器，
because then they just didn't want to deal with people complaining. Nothing is real. Nothing is real. I don't know. Nothing is real. Oh my gosh. I'm going to go live in a cabin in the woods.
因为这样他们就不用应付员工的抱怨了。一切都是假的。一切都是假的。我不知道。一切都是假的。噢，天哪。我要去树林里找间木屋隐居了。
I know our thermostat here at Earwolf works. Because we mess with it all the time. We do. We come in and it's freezing. Crank it down. And we make it hot and then other people come in and make it freezing again. Mm-hmm.
我知道我们耳狼（Earwolf）这里的温控器是管用的。因为我们经常乱动它。我们确实这么做。我们进来时觉得冷得要死。把暖气开到最大。然后我们把它弄得很热，接着其他人进来又把它调得冰冷。嗯-hmm。
So that is happening. I guess the Earwolf bought a building with real thermostat controls. No fake box. Michael is feeling pretty crappy about losing the sale. He's gathered the sales team in the conference room to go over everything. I want to point out at seven minutes 52 seconds
所以这事确实在发生。我猜耳狼买下这栋大楼时带的是真正的温控器。没有假盒子。迈克尔对丢掉这单生意感到非常糟糕。他把销售团队召集到会议室里复盘这一切。我想指出的是，在 7 分 52 秒时
on the whiteboard. It says Danny Cordray, Cymicolon, a real threat exclamation point. Yeah. It's during this meeting that Dwight suggests they lure Danny to the office pretend it's a different office and then they spy on him.
白板上写着：丹尼·科德雷，分号，真正的威胁，感叹号。对。正是在这次会议期间，德怀特建议他们把丹尼引诱到办公室，假装这是另一家公司，然后暗中监视他。
They watch his sales technique. Like the Stinger. Yes. You know that movie with Robert Redford and Paul Newman, The Stinger, where they ride horses. Yeah. I went back and rewatched The Sting.
他们观察他的销售技巧。就像电影《骗中骗》（The Stinger）里那样。对。你知道罗伯特·雷德福（Robert Redford）和保罗·纽曼（Paul Newman）演的那部电影吗，《骗中骗》，他们在里面骑马。对。我回去重看了一遍《骗中骗》。
The whole movie? I didn't get through all of it because it was a little bit late, but almost all of it. It's so good. It's so good. Oh my gosh. The Sting is why I learned to play the entertainer
整部电影？我没看完，因为当时有点晚了，但几乎快看完了。太棒了。太棒了。噢，天哪。《骗中骗》就是我学会如何在钢琴上弹奏《娱乐家》（The Entertainer）的原因。
on the piano. Da-na-na-na-na-na. Yeah. Da-na-na-na-na-na. Yeah. I told my mom I want to learn how to play the entertainer on the piano. We got a piano teacher.
哒-拿-拿-拿-拿-拿。对。哒-拿-拿-拿-拿-拿。对。我告诉我妈我想学在钢琴上弹奏《娱乐家》。我们找了个钢琴老师。
I took piano lessons for like two years. I learned all the chords and the things. Finally, I learned the entertainer and I stopped. Can you still play it? Yes. It's the only thing I can play on the piano because I stopped my lessons as soon as I learned it.
我上了大概两年钢琴课。我学会了所有的和弦和那些东西。最后，我学会了《娱乐家》，然后就不学了。你现在还会弹吗？会。这是我在钢琴上唯一会弹的东西，因为我一学会它就停课了。
But I was obsessed with that movie. I love it. For those of you who haven't seen the Sting, it was a 1973 American caper film involving a complicated plot by two professional grifters to con a mob boss. And those two guys are Robert Redford and Paul Newman. And man, was it fun to rewatch them.
但我对那部电影着迷极了。我太喜欢了。对于那些没看过《骗中骗》的人来说，这是一部 1973 年的美国骗局电影，讲述了两个职业骗子精心策划的一场骗局，旨在骗取一个黑帮老大的钱。那两个人就是罗伯特·雷德福和保罗·纽曼。天哪，重温他们的电影太有趣了。
Robert Redford is so charming. I don't understand Paul Newman's eyes. I really don't understand how you can have eyes that blue. He's so handsome. He's so handsome. And then he made all the salad dressings and he gave all the money to charity. I know.
罗伯特·雷德福太迷人了。我不明白保罗·纽曼的眼睛是怎么长的。我真的不明白一个人的眼睛怎么能蓝成那样。他太帅了。他太帅了。而且他还做了所有的沙拉酱，把所有的钱都捐给了慈善机构。我知道。
I know. Amazing. So they are going to set up this elaborate ruse. Let's just talk about where did this budget come from? Where did the fake sign come from? It says Pennsylvania Solar Tech on the door. They get Meredith to play the head of Pennsylvania Solar Tech. But here's my question.
我知道。太惊人了。所以他们要精心设计这个骗局。我们来聊聊，这笔预算是从哪儿来的？假招牌是从哪儿来的？门上写着“宾州太阳能科技”（Pennsylvania Solar Tech）。他们让梅雷迪思扮演宾州太阳能科技的负责人。但我的问题是。
When they walk Danny in, they have Erin walk Danny in. Yeah. Where did she greet him at the door as he walked in? Did he not see that Dunder Mifflin is also here? I don't know. He's there to meet Meredith Van Helsing. He's focused. I reached out to Kate Flannery about doing these scenes with Timothy Oliphant
当他们把丹尼带进来时，他们让艾琳把丹尼带进来。对。她在门口迎宾时，他走进来没看到达芬·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）也在这里吗？我不知道。他是来见梅雷迪思·范海辛（Meredith Van Helsing）的。他很专注。我联系了凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery），聊了聊和蒂莫西·奥利芬特演这些对手戏的感受，
because she's so good in them. She crushes it. She said, Ange, I was so nervous because I had just watched Deadwood. Oh, Sheriff Seth Bullock. That's all Kate could see. She said she was also excited because she got to have a whole new look for Meredith. She got to wear a nice suit that actually fit her well. She got pretty hair and makeup.
因为她在里面的表现太棒了。她演得绝佳。她说，安吉，我当时紧张极了，因为我刚看过《朽木》（Deadwood）。哦，警长塞斯·布洛克（Seth Bullock）。凯特脑子里全都是这个。她说她也很兴奋，因为她终于能为梅雷迪思换个全新的造型了。她穿上了一套真正合身的漂亮西装。她弄了漂亮的头发和妆容。
And she said shooting the scenes were a blast. She also shared with me she improvised the line, you smell like a Scorpio. That's such a good line. I know. Thanks, Kate. Well, we've got Jim Dwight and Michael and Dwight's like little security office. Whereas Meredith is set up in Dwight's building office. I have a location breakdown for you.
她说拍摄这些场景简直太好玩了。她还跟我分享说，她即兴发挥了这句台词：“你闻起来像个天蝎座。”这台词太棒了。我知道。谢谢你，凯特。好吧，我们有吉姆、德怀特和迈克尔，他们待在德怀特的小保安室里。而梅雷迪思则被安排在德怀特的管理办公室里。我给你们准备了一份拍摄地点分解。
OK. Dwight's surveillance room and Dwight's management office were both built on Stage 2 in our warehouse. For the surveillance office, they actually had four pre-placed lipstick cameras that were really broadcasting into that little surveillance room. Oh, that's so fun. So the guys got to actually watch Kate and Timothy play out these beats. Yes.
好的。德怀特的监控室和德怀特的管理办公室都是在我们的仓库 2 号摄影棚里搭建的。对于监控室，他们实际上预先安装了四个微型口红摄像机，真的把画面直播到那个小监控室里。哦，太有趣了。所以这几个家伙真的能看着凯特和蒂莫西演完全程。对。
Oh, that's so cool. Yes. And it cost about $6,000 to set that up. The little fakie surveillance room. I think we should check in on the band. Yeah, they're down in the warehouse and they're singing their song, Dear Mr. President. Darrell says he doesn't think Andy should sing from the point of view of a little girl. That's weird.
哦，太酷了。是的。搭建那个花了大约 6000 美元。那个小小的假监控室。我觉得我们应该去看看乐队的情况。对，他们在仓库里唱着他们的歌《亲爱的总统先生》（Dear Mr. President）。达瑞尔说他觉得安迪不应该站在一个小女孩的角度来唱歌。这太诡异了。
The lyrics to the song were written by Mindy Kaling and the music was written by Craig Robinson and Ed Helms. These were all original songs. Randy said they even had to create legal contracts between Mindy, Craig, and Ed Helms. And Ed, in order to record and release them. I mean, after watching this episode, I found myself humming. I was like, wait, because I watched it like three times. The line, please, Mr. President, if you want to give hope a whirl,
这首歌的歌词是由明迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）写的，音乐则由克雷格·罗宾逊（Craig Robinson）和艾德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）创作。这些全都是原创歌曲。兰迪说他们甚至必须在明迪、克雷格和艾德·赫尔姆斯之间建立法律合同。还有艾德，为了录制和发行它们。我是说，看完这一集后，我发现自己一直在哼哼。我想，等等，因为我看了大概三遍。歌词“拜托，总统先生，如果你想给希望一个机会，把我们的士兵安然无恙地带回家，这个小女孩在祈求。”就像，我受不了。我受不了。这句词一直在我的脑子里挥之不去。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州约克维尔的 Mag C 的粉丝提问，他说：我 11 岁了，我看这部剧好几年了。我的老师让我们写一篇关于我们最喜欢的名人的论文，我选择了珍娜。马格斯，非常感谢你。
bring our troops home safe and sound, says this little girl. Like, I can't. I can't. Like, it's stuck in my head. We had a fan question from Mag C in Yorkville, Illinois, who said, I am 11 years old and I've watched the show for years. My teacher asked us to write a paper on our favorite celebrity and I chose Jenna. Mags, thank you so much.
马格斯的问题是，那些演奏乐器的人是专业人士吗？好吧，我来告诉你，马格斯，克雷格、艾德和布莱恩其实都是在真的演奏乐器。我会把克雷格和艾德归类为达到专业音乐家水平的人。我不确定我是否会把布莱恩归为那一类。布莱恩，无意冒犯。公平地说，布莱恩会是第一个告诉你的人，每当他有这些戏份时，他都会紧张得要命，因为他说：伙计们，我不是音乐家。你们才是。
Mag's question is, were the people who played the instruments professionals? Well, I'll tell you, Mags, Craig, Ed, and Brian were all really playing their instruments. I would classify Craig and Ed as being at the level of a professional musician. I'm not sure I would put Brian there. Brian, no offense. To be fair, Brian would be the first person to tell you that whenever he had these scenes, he would be so nervous because he's like, guys, I am not a musician. You guys are.
兰迪说，当他们录制这些场景时，他们是把人声和乐器伴奏一起现场录制的。他说这后来成了一个问题，因为当国际销售团队去向海外销售这部剧时，他们无法进行配音，因为人声无法从音乐中分离出来。哦。所以兰迪不得不回去。他不得不雇佣音乐作曲家伊夫·纳尔逊（Eve Nelson）来制作单独的键盘、鼓，
Randy said that when they recorded these scenes, they recorded the vocals and the instrumentals together live. And he said this was a problem later because when the international sales team went to sell the show internationally, they couldn't dub the voices because they couldn't separate it from the music. Oh. So Randy had to go back. He had to hire music composer Eve Nelson to create separate keyboard, drums,
和吉他，重新录制音乐，然后将其与配音的外语人声同步。这简直是个大工程。哇。好吧，安迪要为整个团队演奏这首歌，他真的很想要诚实的反馈。这首歌能成名吗，比如用在汽车广告什么的里面？我太喜欢瑞安的反应了。对，我知道。瑞安太损了。
and guitar and re-record the music and then sync it with the dubbed foreign language vocals. It was the whole thing. Wow. Well, Andy is going to play the song for the whole group and he really wants honest feedback. Could the song be famous, like in a car commercial or something? I loved Ryan's response. Yeah, I know. The Ryan's ass.
还有吉他，重新录制音乐，然后将其与配音的外语人声同步。就是这么回事。哇。嗯，安迪将为整个团队演奏这首歌，他非常希望得到诚实的反馈。这首歌能红吗，比如出现在汽车广告里什么的？我很喜欢瑞安的回答。是的，我知道。瑞安太逗了。
Ryan is so snarky. When he asks if maybe someone might skate to it at the Olympics, he's like, I don't think so because they don't usually skate to such bad songs. And then what really seals the deal that it's not going to be a hit is that Creed said he really liked it. Yeah. And then Andy's like, oh, that really pumps me out. At 11 minutes 43 seconds,
瑞安真是尖酸刻薄。当他问有没有人在奥运会上滑冰时用这首歌，他觉得不会，因为他们通常不会用这么烂的歌。然后真正一锤定音、证明这首歌不会火的原因是，克里德说他真的很喜欢。然后安迪就说，哦，这真让我泄气。在11分钟43秒时，
I noticed that I'm holding Pam's pink mug. I noticed that too. And you're all in pink, kind of. It was like a whole pink thing happening. Well, forgive me if I've said this on the podcast before, but that mug broke. I had that mug for all nine seasons and in the ninth season it broke. And they glued it back together for me and I keep it on my bookshelf. But I have a late breaking development about Pam's pink mug.
我注意到我拿着帕姆的粉色马克杯。我也注意到了。而且你穿得也差不多全是粉色。就好像发生了一场粉色的整体事件。好吧，如果我在播客里说过这个，请原谅，但那个杯子碎了。我用了整整九季那个杯子，但在第九季它碎了。他们把它给我粘好了，我把它放在书架上。但我对帕姆的粉色马克杯有一个最新进展。
It didn't break again, did it? No. What happened? What happened? I found a woman who makes replicas. Did you order yourself one? I did. And it's really great. It's this woman named Linda Renee Pottery from Bluffton, Ohio.
它没有又碎了吧？没有。怎么了？怎么了？我找到了一位制作复制品的女士。你给自己订了一个吗？我订了。而且真的超棒。这位女士叫琳达·雷妮陶艺（Linda Renee Pottery），来自俄亥俄州布拉夫顿。
She has an Etsy shop. All of her pottery is beautiful. You know, I love handmade things. She first made the mug as a special order item because someone requested it. And I guess I randomly saw this post on Twitter. I happen to see it. I'm so glad I did because I went on and I ordered one and I love it. It's like a really good match. It's like I have Pam's pink mug again.
她有一个Etsy店铺。她所有的陶艺作品都很漂亮。你知道的，我喜欢手工制品。她最初制作这个马克杯是作为特殊定制商品，因为有人提出了请求。我想我是偶然在推特上看到了这个帖子。我碰巧看到了。我很高兴我看到了，因为我去下单了一个，而且我很喜欢。这真的很匹配。就像我又有了帕姆的粉色马克杯一样。
You have to give us a photo of it. I will. Well, I know how much Pam's mug meant to you and I'm so happy you have another one. I know me too. Things are going to heat up a little bit at solar tech. Danny takes off his jacket. Meredith is thrilled. And pretty quickly, Michael has to call her and tell her to pull it together.
你得给我们发张照片。我会的。嗯，我知道帕姆的杯子对你意味着什么，我很高兴你又有一个了。我知道，我也是。太阳科技公司（Solar Tech）的气氛要开始变得有点紧张了。丹尼脱下了夹克。梅雷迪思欣喜若狂。很快，迈克尔就不得不叫住她，让她收敛一点。
Yeah, but she's not going to listen. No, she is not. She is going to unbutton her blouse. And she is going to walk around the desk to get closer to Danny. Well, Danny says we should think of this as a first date. And Meredith's like, how about a third date? And then Michael calls her and she says, shut up. Let me do this and hangs up on him.
是啊，但她才不会听呢。不，她才不听。她要解开衬衫纽扣。她要绕过办公桌去靠近丹尼。好吧，丹尼说我们应该把这当作第一次约会。梅雷迪思却说，第三次约会怎么样？然后迈克尔打电话给她，她说，闭嘴。让我来处理，然后就挂了他的电话。
They're going to need to call in some reinforcements. Oscar. And Jim says, listen, you're an exec at Pennsylvania Solar Tech. And Dwight's like, no, Stark Industries. He keeps pushing Stark Industries. Oscar walks in to take over the meeting. Meredith is like, oh, Manuel, this is Manuel, my cleaning man. He doesn't speak any English.
他们需要叫一些援兵来。奥斯卡。吉姆说，听着，你是宾夕法尼亚太阳科技公司的执行高管。德怀特却说，不，是斯塔克工业（Stark Industries）。他一直推说是斯塔克工业。奥斯卡走进来接管会议。梅雷迪思就说，哦，曼努埃尔，这是曼努埃尔，我的清洁工。他一句英语都不会说。
Go clean the windows. She just silences him immediately. So now I need another person. They're panicking. They grab Ryan. They give him the same speech. Ryan wants to say that he worked at Google. They're like, just get in there.
去擦窗户。她马上就让他闭嘴了。所以现在我需要另一个人。他们慌了。他们抓住了瑞安。他们对瑞安说了同样的话。瑞安想说他在谷歌工作过。他们说，别废话，快进去。
And then Ryan walks in and right away she goes, Esteban, another cleaning man, doesn't speak English. Clean the floor. Yeah. Did you notice that 12 minutes and 25 seconds were inside the little surveillance office? And the television that is the single on Danny's face is labeled Alpha Cam.
然后瑞安走进去，她立刻就说，埃斯特班，另一个清洁工，不会说英语。去擦地。对啊。你有没有注意到在12分钟25秒时，我们在监控小办公室里？电视上特写丹尼脸部的画面被标为“阿尔法摄像机”（Alpha Cam）。
I don't know because he's the alpha male is what made me think of, I was like, oh, I like that. Meredith is really pouring it on now. She's like, Danny, I feel a real connection to you. And Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no. They're like, no, no, they run in. He busts in. Yeah.
我不知道，因为他是“阿尔法男”（alpha male），这让我想到了……我当时就想，哦，我喜欢这个。梅雷迪思现在真的是在疯狂示爱。她说，丹尼，我感觉和你有种真正的精神连接。迈克尔就说，不不不不不。他们说，不不，他们跑了进去。他冲了进去。对。
He's like, stop, stop. And he confesses everything. And rats out Dwight and Jim. They're in on it too. It's amazing. So now Danny is leaving. He's running down the hallway. Michael is following him, pleading with him.
他喊道，住手，住手。然后他招供了一切。并把德怀特和吉姆给出卖了。他们也参与其中。太绝了。所以现在丹尼要走了。他在走廊里跑着。迈克尔在后面追他，恳求他。
Okay. You know that that hallway was our real hallway that led to our little lobby. It was outside of our editor's offices. Yeah. That in no way connected to these actual rooms, which were over on the warehouse stage. So when they leave the little room, you'll notice there's a cut and then they're in the hallway.
好吧。你知道那条走廊是我们通往小大厅的真实走廊吗？它在我们的剪辑师办公室外面。对。那条走廊根本不通往这些实际的房间，那些房间是在仓库摄影棚那边。所以当他们离开那个小房间时，你会注意到有一个镜头剪辑，然后他们就在走廊里了。
So they had to like bring that energy to two different locations. But all of it when Oscars coming down the hallway, when Ryan's coming down the hallway, none of that was actually connected to the rooms. They had to stitch it. They did. They had a whole afternoon of hallway work.
所以他们必须把那种情绪带到两个不同的地方。但所有这些——当奥斯卡走过走廊时，当瑞安走过走廊时——其实都和那些房间不相连。他们必须把它们剪辑拼凑起来。确实如此。他们花了一整个下午拍摄走廊的戏份。
Michael finally says, look, Danny, I will give you a better job here. Look what you did at this other company that doesn't have near the clients or reach that we have. Just imagine what you could do here. And Danny is intrigued. The wheels are turning. Mm-hmm.
迈克尔最后说，听着，丹尼，我在这里给你一份更好的工作。看看你在那家既没有我们这样的客户、也没有我们这样影响力的公司都做了什么。想象一下你在这里能大有一番作为。丹尼被吸引了。他的大脑在飞速运转。嗯。
He's going to accept Michael's offer. Yes. And there was a deleted Danny Cordray talking to me. Danny Cordray talking head about why he took the job. Oh. Why would I agree to work here? Well, I feel like Pam and I have some unfinished business. And if Jim gets burned in the process,
他要接受迈克尔的邀请了。是的。还有一个被删减的丹尼·科德雷的访谈。丹尼·科德雷关于他为什么接受这份工作的访谈。哦。我为什么会同意在这里工作？嗯，我觉得我和帕姆之间还有些未了的情缘。如果吉姆在这个过程中被坑了，
well, that's just going to be too bad for him. I'm just kidding. They offered me a stupid amount of money. It got you, didn't it? It totally got me. Isn't that a good one? Yes. Yes, I was like, I don't remember this.
那对他来说也只能算他倒霉了。我开玩笑的。他们给了我一大笔愚蠢的钱。你中招了吧，对不对？我完全中招了。这不是挺逗的吗？是的。是的，我当时想，我不记得这个了。
Yeah. Oh, my goodness. Oh, I wish that had stated. And then how much money did Michael offer him? Oh, my gosh. I don't know. And later, Michael is going to remember I already have a traveling salesman.
是啊。哦，天哪。哦，我真希望这段留下来了。然后迈克尔到底给了他多少钱？哦，天哪。我不知道。后来，迈克尔想起来，我其实已经有一个出差销售员了。
It's Todd Packer. Yeah. Ah. Well, Michael's going to announce it to the whole office. He's going to bring him up. Kelly has a big reaction to meeting Danny, and it caused the standards and practices flurry of emails. It was the F-bomb.
就是托德·帕克（Todd Packer）。对啊。啊。好吧，迈克尔要向整个办公室宣布这件事。他要把他带上来。凯莉对见到丹尼反应很大，这引发了一连串关于“标准与实践”（Standards and Practices）的电子邮件。那是F开头的脏话。
After the table reading, we got a note that said this. Page 32, please bleep Kelly's f**k. Remark, completely with no beginning or end consonant sounds. And blur the visible lip flap. They don't like the lip flap. They are all over the lip flaps. You're going to lose the audio, and we will not be able to tell she's saying for f**k.
在围读剧本之后，我们收到了一条备注，内容如下：第32页，请把凯莉的f**k消音。备注：完全没有开头或结尾的辅音发音。并且模糊处理可见的嘴唇动作。他们不喜欢嘴唇动作。他们对嘴唇动作抓得很紧。你会失去音频，而且我们无法看出她在说for f**k。
Well, I guess after they locked the editor's cut, they had to send it back. And here's the note they got. As previously noted, please blur Kelly's lips when she says f**k. Please blur the fricking lip flap. How many times do I have to say it? These a**holes in the office never blur the lip flap. Oh my gosh, can we please meet this person?
好吧，我想在他们锁定剪辑版之后，他们不得不把它送回去。这是他们收到的备注：如前所述，当凯莉说f**k时，请模糊处理她的嘴唇。请模糊处理那该死的嘴唇动作！我还要说多少遍？办公室里的这些混蛋从来不模糊处理嘴唇动作！哦天哪，我们能见见这个人吗？
Well, Kelly is happy, but the sales team is not. They are not. They are going to go into Michael's office and tell them that Danny is going to steal their clients. Well, I want to point out two things. The first is, from 17 minutes and 37 seconds until 18 minutes and 15 seconds, you can see Danny Cordray standing outside of Michael's office
好吧，凯莉很高兴，但销售团队可不高兴。他们才不高兴呢。他们要走进迈克尔的办公室，告诉他丹尼会抢走他们的客户。好吧，我想指出两点。首先，从17分37秒到18分15秒，你能看到丹尼·科德雷站在迈克尔的办公室外面，
in the background of this scene. Timothy Oliphant had to stand there the whole entire scene. That's what you need to know. He was just standing there. Also, for my background catch, folks, did anyone else notice that there are no toys, not a single one? No toys on Michael's desk. Did anyone notice, Angela?
在这个场景的背景里。蒂莫西·奥利芬特（Timothy Oliphant）不得不站在那里拍完整场戏。这就是你们需要知道的。他当时就站在那儿。另外，对于那些喜欢寻找背景细节的朋友们，有没有人注意到里面没有任何玩具，连一个都没有？迈克尔的桌上没有玩具。大家注意到了吗，安吉拉？
We got a fan mail flurry about it. Yes. Brooke Jay from Montana, Maggie E. from Tennessee, and many others said, why is Michael's office more empty than usual and there aren't any toys on his desk? Not a one. Also, Christian H. from Independence, Missouri.
我们收到了雪片般飞来的粉丝来信。是的。来自蒙大拿州的布鲁克·杰伊、来自田纳西州的玛吉·E以及许多其他人都在问，为什么迈克尔的办公室比平时更空，而且他的桌上没有任何玩具？一个都没有。还有来自密苏里州独立城的克里斯蒂安·H。
It seemed like the bookshelves were missing from Michael's office toward the end of the episode. What happened to them? Is there a deleted scene or something we don't know about? Yeah, what happened? Was it that time there was that funky smell in Michael's office in the carpet, and they had to pull it up?
看起来在剧集接近尾声时，迈克尔办公室的书架不见了。它们怎么了？是有被删减的场景还是我们不知道的其他情况？是的，怎么回事？是不是那次迈克尔办公室的地毯上有股怪味，所以他们不得不把地毯掀了？
I have the memory of this. You mean, like, in real life or fictionally? In real life. No, I never remember that. There was a funky smell, and they had to disassemble the Michael Scott office? I have a memory of that. We should ask Randy.
我对这个有记忆。你是说，在现实生活中还是在虚构的故事里？在现实生活中。不，我一点都不记得那回事。有股怪味，然后他们不得不把迈克尔·斯科特的办公室拆了？我对这个有记忆。我们应该问问兰迪。
I just remember one time it got a little stinky. Okay, I don't remember that. But I mean, I'm just assuming that they used all of Michael's stuff to create the Meredith Van Helsing office, and that's where all his furniture went. I'm sorry, they did not use any of his toys in Meredith Van Helsing's office. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, they used his mug?
我只记得有一次那里变得有点臭。好吧，我不记得了。但我的意思是，我只是假设他们用了迈克尔的所有东西来布置梅雷迪思·范海辛（Meredith Van Helsing）的办公室，他的所有家具都搬到那里去了。不好意思，他们在梅雷迪思·范海辛的办公室里根本没用他的任何玩具。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，他们用了他的马克杯？
Well, the mug, and he points it out to which Jim says, you know, this isn't a real TV show. But were his clackety teeth there with his little squishy ball that goes in and out? I don't know. Were the little clacky balls there? I don't know. Maybe the clacky balls were there.
好吧，马克杯用了，而且他还特意指了出来，吉姆对此评价说，你知道，这不是一个真正的电视节目。但是他那副会咔哒作响的假牙还在吗，还有他那个能捏来捏去的软球？我不知道。那些咔哒作响的小球还在吗？我不知道。也许咔哒球还在吧？
We didn't look close enough. There were no clacky balls. Who wants those? Why do you need them? Sam, go and film them. Why are you watching them? What does it bring your desk to have balls clacking back and forth?
我们当时没仔细看。根本没有咔哒球。谁会想要那些东西？你为什么需要它们？山姆，去拍一下它们。你为什么一直在看它们？把来回咔哒作响的球放在桌上到底能带来什么？
What is it? Who invented it? Well, I never got to the bottom of it. I still don't get it. Are they relaxing? What is it? I like the clacky balls. Sam got us each a little pair of clacky balls,
这算什么？谁发明的？好吧，我一直没弄明白。我还是搞不懂。它们能让人放松吗？到底是什么？我挺喜欢咔哒球的。山姆给我们每人买了一小套咔哒球，
and Sam, I've been wanting to tell you this for some time. They were sitting on a low shelf in my home office, and we had a friend whose toddler came over, and in maybe five seconds put all the clacky balls in one giant knot that no one has been able to undo. We now give it as a challenge to people who come over. Like, can you undo what a toddler did in five seconds? No one's been able to do it.
山姆，我有些话想跟你说很久了。它们曾放在我家办公室的一个矮书架上，我们有个朋友带他的幼儿来家里做客，大概只用了五秒钟，就把所有的咔哒球系成了一个谁也解不开的巨大死结。现在我们把它当成一个挑战，给来家里做客的人玩。比如，你能解开一个两三岁小孩在五秒钟内系成的结吗？没有人能解开。
That makes me actually very happy. I'm going to take a picture of it. Please do. I understand that it's like some sort of physics phenomenon of clacky balls, but I just don't understand how they became such a popular desk item. I just don't get it. I'm going to deep dive it.
这实际上让我非常高兴。我要给它拍张照片。请务必拍一张。我明白这就像是咔哒球的某种物理现象，但我就是不明白它们怎么会变成如此受欢迎的办公桌小物件。我就是搞不懂。我要深入研究一下。
Maybe it's a special episode of Office Ladies' bonus episode, Clacky Balls. Where did they come from? How did they rise in popularity? Well, I will tune in for your Clacky Balls episode. You're going to be there, lady. Oh, I'll be there. Okay.
也许这会是《办公室女士》的一个特别版、彩蛋集——《咔哒球》。它们是从哪里来的？它们是怎么变得风靡起来的？好吧，我会收听你的“咔哒球”特集的。你到时候也会在的，女士。哦，我会在的。好吧。
Look for it this winter. Yeah. Special episode, bonus episode. Office Ladies' semicolon, Clacky Balls. Well, Michael is going to try to convince the sales team that things are going to get better. They are. That Danny being there will no longer be a threat.
今年冬天敬请期待。是的。特别集，彩蛋集。《办公室女士》分号——《咔哒球》。好吧，迈克尔要试图说服销售团队事情会好转的。他们会的。丹尼的到来将不再是一个威胁。
He'll now be an asset. Right after this, Danny is going to tell Jim that he and Pam went on a few dates way back, but that Pam wasn't into him. Didn't call him back. Yeah. Uh-oh. Jim's like, she told me.
他现在将成为一个资产。紧接着，丹尼会告诉吉姆，他和帕姆很久以前约会过几次，但帕姆对并不他感冒。没有给他回电话。啊哦。吉姆说，她跟我说过。
I know. But then Dwight overhears this and has such a strong reaction. He's like, let me handle this, Jim. Drop the act, Cordray. Okay. We all know that you probably thought that Pam was just too meh or thin without being toned. But I want to tell you something.
我知道。但随后德怀特无意中听到了这话，反应非常强烈。他说，让我来处理这件事，吉姆，别装了，科德雷。好吧。我们都知道，你可能觉得帕姆要么太索然无味，要么身材不够健美。但我想告诉你一件事。
She is one of the plain, hearty women of Scranton that make this city great. And so what if she doesn't wear makeup? Lady, well, we did the table read, and I heard the line thin without being toned. I laughed so hard. I was like, that is such an accurate description of my physique. I was like, they nailed it.
她是斯克兰顿那些朴实、坚韧的女性之一，正是她们让这座城市变得伟大。就算她不化妆又怎样？女士们，我们在围读剧本时，当我听到“身材不够健美”这句台词时，我笑得前仰后合。我心想，这对我身材的描述简直太准确了。我当时想，他们抓得太准了。
And it was so funny to me. I loved when Pam mouths to the camera. I wear makeup. Also, I love he describes her as meh. Meh. That was very funny. Oh my goodness. Dwight is also going to accuse Danny of being a thief,
我觉得这太搞笑了。我特别喜欢帕姆对着镜头做口型说：我化了妆。另外，我喜欢他用“索然无味”来形容她。索然无味。这太搞笑了。天哪。德怀特接下来还要指责丹尼是个小偷，
but then finds out it's five o'clock and shakes his hand. No, he's not going to take that home with him. He's not going to take that energy home. Well, even though Andy, Darryl, and Kevin were all upstairs to meet Danny Cordray, they are also simultaneously down in the warehouse. I don't know if you noticed this editing. Yeah.
但随后发现已经五点钟了，于是跟他握了手。不，他可不会把那种情绪带回家。他才不会把那种负能量带回家呢。好吧，尽管安迪、达里尔和凯文当时都在楼上见丹尼·科德雷，但他们同时也出现在了楼下的仓库里。我不知道你们有没有注意到这个剪辑。对。
They managed to be in two places at once. They're magic. And they're down there. And first, Andy tries to write a song from the heart. It's OK. But they've run out of time. But guess what? Darryl is going to stay, and he's going to jam for free.
他们设法同时出现在两个地方。他们有魔法。他们到了楼下。首先，安迪试图创作一首发自内心的歌。还行。但他们的时间不多了。不过你猜怎么着？达里尔要留下来，他要免费即兴合奏。
Yeah. Andy's so happy. And as a result, they are going to write a fabulous song. It's titled Croak, Croak, Croak, Bullfrog, and Love. We had a fan question from Nicole S. in Seattle, Washington who wanted to know who wrote Bullfrog and Love because it's really great. Well, this one was lyrics by Mindy Kaling
太好了，安迪高兴极了。结果，他们创作了一首绝妙的歌。歌名叫《呱、呱、呱，牛蛙与爱》。我们收到了来自华盛顿州西雅图市的粉丝尼可·S.的提问，她想知道是谁写了《牛蛙与爱》，因为这首歌真的很棒。好吧，这首歌由曼迪·卡灵作词，
and music by Eve Nelson. It is very good, very catchy. Well, Nicole, we agree with you. It's pretty awesome. And we all think you need to hear it. Starts in her eyes, tongue full of flies. Would you like to share my past? Croak, croak, croak, Bullfrog and Love.
伊芙·尼尔森作曲。这首歌非常好，非常洗脑。好吧，尼可，我们和你一样。这歌简直太棒了。我们都觉得你们得听听看。始于她的双眼，舌头沾满苍蝇。你愿意分享我的过去吗？呱，呱，呱，牛蛙与爱。
Croak, croak, croak, Bullfrog and Love. Then I gave her the croak. The man, I love you. I'll be your croak, monsieur. I'll be your croak, my dad. Your mama, mine said that Bullfrog's a dog. But I'm here to tell you that I am a frog. Come and sit on my lawn, you little polywog.
呱，呱，呱，牛蛙与爱。然后我给了她那声“呱”。老兄，我爱你。我会做你的“呱”，先生。我会做你的“呱”，爹地。你妈，我爸说牛蛙就是条狗。但我来告诉你，其实我是一只青蛙。来坐在我的草坪上吧，你这个小蝌蚪。
I find you absolutely riveting. Croak, croak, croak, Bullfrog and Love. Croak, croak, croak, Bullfrog and Love. Croak, rivet, scoop, splash. Oh, everybody, that was the sting. Thank you to Randy Cordray, Kate Flannery and James Carey, and of course to Craig Robinson. Oh, Craig, it was so great to see you.
我觉得你绝对引人入胜。呱，呱，呱，牛蛙与爱。呱，呱，呱，牛蛙与爱。呱，铆钉，舀，水花。哦，各位，这就是片尾的音效。感谢兰迪·科德雷、凯特·弗兰内利、詹姆斯·凯里，当然还有克雷格·罗宾逊。哦，克雷格，见到你太棒了。
Craig, it was awesome. And you guys, if you want to check out Craig's shows, go to MrCraigRobinson.com, that's his website. You can see where he's touring around the country, and you can check out Killing It on Peacock. We all find you riveting. And we hope you have a great week. We'll see you next time.
克雷格，太棒了。各位，如果你想关注克雷格的演出，请访问 MrCraigRobinson.com，那是他的网站。你可以查看他在全国各地的巡演行程，还可以在Peacock上观看《绝命好律师》（Killing It）。我们都觉得你们太迷人了。祝大家度过美好的一周。我们下期再见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的《橡胶树》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。